[Musique]
john palais bonjour baja nous vous
recevons aujourd'hui pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle thinker view nous
sommes en direct on vous reçoit dans le
cadre de vos activités on va vous
laisser vous présenter qui êtes vous
qu'est ce que vous faites
l'essentiel de mon temps je
j'ai milite pour l'écologie et plus
précisément pour contrôler dérèglement
climatique mais
en ayant une conscience une conception
du dérèglement climatique comme étant un
enjeu qui qui conditionne tous les
autres enjeux qui me semble important
celui la justice sociale celui de la
paix celui de la biodiversité à celui de
la démocratie puisque tous ces enjeux
sont sont des batailles importantes mais
qui sont des batailles différentes dans
un monde au climat à peu près stable à 1
degrés de réchauffement comme comme on
est aujourd'hui et ce sont des batailles
différentes dans une sur une planète
avec un réchauffement à 2 degrés 3° ou 4
degrés qu'est ce que vous avez à
répondre aux gens qui contestent le
réchauffement climatique
[Musique]
jeu
je n'ai pas eu débat pas vraiment avec
les gens qui contestent le dérèglement
climatique parce que ça ça nous fait
perdre du temps et j'ai l'impression que
pour beaucoup c'est des personnes qui
seront les derniers à être convaincus ou
en tout cas qui ont choisi de pas être
convaincus aussi
et le temps c'est ce qui nous manque le
plus dans cette bataille là donc je me
dis que le
ya
un certain nombre de climato sceptiques
et un nombre beaucoup plus grand de
personnes qui sont pas climato
sceptiques mais qui n'ont quand même pas
vraiment compris l'arrêt à l'urgence est
la réelle gravité du règlement
climatique et qui se sont pas engagés
dans les alternatives
le changement de mode de vie qu'on a
besoin de faire pour limiter
l'aggravation du dérèglement climatique
donc je pense que le l'énergie il faut
la mettre à convaincre ces personnes là
soit de ce qu'est vraiment le
dérèglement climatique soit du fait
qu'on peut y faire quelque chose qu'elle
quelles sont les principales menaces que
vous avez identifié et que le
réchauffement climatique va mettre en
exergue
c'est très vaste
le plus évident je pense que c'est laid
les événements climatiques extrêmes donc
le ce que nous disent les climatologues
c'est plus on réchauffe la planète et
plus on a une multiplication et une
intensification des ces événements là
donc c'est les cyclones et tempêtes
les sécheresses
les inondations parce qu'on population
alors du coup ça c'est celle et les
impacts secondaires dus aux premières
c'est aussi une baisse des rendements
agricoles
c'est la montée des océans donc ça veut
dire que tout ça combiné ont pas
combiner d'ailleurs mais en tout cas
détruit des espaces habitables où vivent
où vivent des gens la montée des eaux je
crois qu'on est la moitié de la
population mondiale qui vit à moins de
100 kilomètres d'une cote dont des très
grandes villes l'eau va monter donc les
gens vont devoir se déplacer oui ça les
déplacements population c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut anticiper avec beaucoup
de sérieux parce qu'on voit déjà
aujourd'hui qu'on en a une gestion
catastrophique
enfin c'est
là on vit une crise migratoire en europe
et moi je suis quand même la fin j'ai
honte de la manière dont l'europe qui
est
une des premières puissances du monde
ne peut pas accueillir dignement des
personnes qui fuient
qui fuient des dangers qui fuient la
misère
call back ground zero
moi j'ai
un background artistique
j'ai fait des études d'arts plastiques
l'art du spectacle
montage audiovisuel
vous êtes sensibles vous travaillez avec
vos sens
jeux
wii
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à prendre
cette cause simplement
le bon
l'origine
moi j'ai grandi dans les années 80
j'ai 39 ans comme macron
non il a 40 ans maintenant c'est ça le
vous avez une bougie
très le
j'ai grandi dans les oueds chine et en
bonne idée pourquoi
le bal année de la première catastrophe
nucléaire par exemple a three miles
island les bons et moi il me semble que
dès les années 80 il y avait déjà
énormément d'informations qui nous
montrait que ce qui se passait et est
grave au niveau écologique là quand même
dans les années 2010 c'est un thème que
tout le monde a en tête
il me semble que dans les années 80
c'était quand même plus
dissidents comme thème quoi c'était
c'était c'était perçu comme un pis mais
des hippies ou des marchés non puisque
avait aussi des scientifiques etc mais
en tout cas c'était des marginaux qui
présentait la cause de l'écologie comme
une cause comme une cause centrale
s'étaient dits marginaux où il était
présenté que marginaux
je sais pas mais en tout cas c'était un
thème marginal et on était facilement
marché marginalisés bon moi j'avais
entre j'avais entre un et dix ans donc
je mets c'est le regard que j'emporte a
posteriori mais dans les années 80 ou 90
on entendait déjà parler la
déforestation alors non à l'époque on
entendait beaucoup parler du trou dans
la couche d'ozone le
mais le dérèglement climatique étaient
déjà identifiés par par des
scientifiques avant de devenir ce thème
aussi aussi important on entendait déjà
parler de la disparition d'espèces
vivantes on entendait déjà parler de la
destruction d'écosystèmes moi ça m'a
toujours semblé
très grave le aujourd'hui maintenant on
a une conscience des enjeux écologiques
qui a
qui a changé parce qu'elle est elle est
très étayées scientifiquement
et même si il ya des climato sceptiques
mais il y en aura toujours le caecum ya
encore des gens qui disent que la terre
est plate donc on attend on n'atteindra
jamais 100% de personnes qui pensent que
la terre est plate ou qu'il n'y a pas de
dérèglement climatique enfin qu'il ya un
dérèglement climatique
le don qu'il ya il ya une légitimité
maintenant de ce thème qui est
différente on considère quand même
globalement que que les scientifiques
sont d'accord
au niveau où ils peuvent être d'accord
sur le fait que le dérèglement
climatique en cours est très grave et
que globalement la crise écologique
engagé menace les conditions de vie
civilisée sur terre à brève échéance
c'est-à-dire dans les décennies qui
viennent au cours de ce siècle donc dans
la vie que vont vivre les enfants qui
sont déjà nés
et menace aussi les conditions de sur
vie tout court de l'humanité selon le
degré de réchauffement combat qu'on va
atteindre donc l'enjeu c'est de savoir
on est entré dans le dérèglement
climatique
il ya une part de la catastrophe qui est
navy table il ya une part de la
catastrophe que des gens vivent déjà
beaucoup plus durement que nous en
europe notamment notamment en afrique
notamment dans l'est et dans les états
insulaires le sait déjà une tragédie
pour des millions de personnes ça va
forcément s'aggraver parce que même si
on coupe tout les robinets de gaz à
effet de serre aujourd'hui le mieux
aussi mais voilà c'est à dire qu'il ya
ça met un certain temps à produire
l'effet de serre et à dérégler tous les
mécanismes tous les mécanismes de la
planète le donc même si on coupe les
robinets aujourd'hui bon ça continuera
de s'aggraver mais ça veut pas dire que
il faut y aller encore pire c'est à dire
que la question c'est juste jusqu'où
jusqu'où on va aggraver la situation ou
plutôt à quel niveau on va réussir à
endiguer le réchauffement climatique et
ça moi je refuse d'entendre que c'est
une cause perdue au prétexte qu'on a
commencé à la perdre c'est pas trop tard
pour vous de voter contre mais c'est à
dire c'est non puisque c'est graduelle
c'est à dire que pour l'instant il ya
encore des énergies fossiles dans le sol
qu'on est encore en train d'extraire et
qu'on est encore en train de brûler donc
à chaque fois qu'on ouvre une centrale à
charbon en empire la situation à chaque
fois que ont produit des bonnes des
barils de pétrole on aggrave la
situation à chaque fois qu'on arrive à
empêcher une centrale à charbon de
s'ouvrir ou à empêcher une projet de
sables bitumineux de se développer ben
on limite l'aggravation du dérèglement
climatique vous arrivez limitée
d'aggravation en chine on ouvre combien
de centrales à charbon par an chinois
c'est l'excès alors la chine alors je
suis pas ce pas un connaisseur mais
beaucoup de centrales à charbon beaucoup
d'énergies renouvelables aussi
le je veux pas critiquer comme ça la
chine aussi facilement parce qu'elle n'a
pas la même responsabilité historique
dans le dérèglement climatique actuel
que l'europe ou les états unis donc je
trouve que c'est un peu facile et
surtout de notre part en europe et aux
états unis de dire oui la chine l'inde
le brésil ils sont super nombreux nos
efforts à nous sont dérisoires et
finalement c'est pas nous changer
puisque les chinois sont tellement
nombreux que ses aveux donc c'est très
contestable
d'abord parce que c'est nous les
occidentaux qui avons engagé ce modèle
de développement qui suivit donc on en a
une on avait même une responsabilité
indirecte dans dans le modèle de
développement de la chine deuxièmement
j'ai entendu dire mais je serais pas
capable de donner des détails mais que
sur certains secteurs ils font beaucoup
plus d'efforts que nous le soin les
énergies renouvelables sur les
investissements vont ils sont aussi très
confrontés à des problèmes de pollution
bon voilà c'est des situations
différentes
et d'autre part il ya quand même une
quantité énorme de la production
chinoise qui est exporté pour notre
consommation donc ça dépend aussi
comment comment vous fait le calcul est
ce qu'il faut calculer les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre où elles sont
produites ou pourquoi elles sont
produites et où c'est consommer parce
que moi je suis je veux bien être le
premier a demandé qu'on arrête de
consommer des produits chinois fin en
tout cas d'une manière générale des
produits qui font quatre fois le tour de
la planète avant qu on les consomme vous
avez entamé un dialogue avec les
pouvoirs publics ou des choses comme ça
me sapin le contact direct avec les
forces de l'ordre
alors le
alternatiba et à action non violente
comme 21 kg risque alternatiba qu'est-ce
que actions non violentes comme 21 et
alternatiba c'est deux mouvements
citoyens dans lesquels dans lesquels je
milite
pour nous c'est un petit peu
ces deux mouvements qui sont nés
séparément avec chacun leur leur mode
opératoire
alternatiba c'était mettre en lumière
les alternatives qui existent déjà sur
nos territoires d'autres manières de se
nourrir et de produire des aliments
d'autres manières de se déplacer
d'autres manières de produire de
l'énergie et on a commencé à organiser
ce qu'on appelait alors c'est parti à
bayonne de bayonne un village des
alternatives on a fermé le centre ville
de bayonne à la circulation automobile
nombreux sont les basques voilà et on a
transformé chaque rue chaque place du
centre-ville en en espace de deux
démonstrations des alternatives et par
thème il y avait la place de
l'agriculture paysanne la rue de
l'économie solidaire et c'est avec
l'aval des pouvoirs publics alors je
vais y venir le d'abord on se pose pas
la question de l'aval des pouvoirs
publics on se pose la question de
quelles sont les solutions et comment on
peut inviter les gens à s'en emparer le
la pour ce projet là on s'est posée
après la question de est ce que les
pouvoirs publics allait nous laisser
faire ou pas
le
ces alternatives du coup c'était un
moment je donne un peu le contexte parce
que c'était en octobre 2013 et en
octobre 2013 il n'y avait pas
le climat était pas aussi identifié
qu'aujourd'hui y compris dans l'est dans
les milieux militants il ya eu un grand
pic au moment du sommet de copenhague en
2009 où il ya eu une convergence inédite
entre des mouvements altermondialistes
des mouvements écologistes des
mouvements de solidarité internationale
qui eux sur beaucoup de beaucoup de
moments travail chacun dans leur secteur
et autour du sommet de copenhague c'est
un moment où on a été très nombreux à
comprendre que tous ces enjeux étaient
interconnectés le climat est une sorte
de d'enjeu global qui fait que les
écologistes les altermondialistes et
ceux qui bataillait sur la solidarité
internationale voyez bien que tout ça
des pommes enfin le climat en tout cas
elle est déterminée des conditions de
tous ces enjeux-là mais hélas c'est lié
aux pouvoirs publics déjà à copenhague
le sait que la revendication portée par
le parent l'essentiel du mouvement
c'était un accord international
ambitieux
juste et juridiquement contraignant
et beaucoup de gens pensaient que
c'était possible
on a bataillé là dessus le c'était un
moment historique le c'était bon hein
c'est ce qu'on appelle les coop les
conférence de l'onu sur le climat qui
ont lieu chaque année mais c'est des
processus sur plusieurs années puis il
ya un moment il faut aboutir un accord
et en 2009 on était censé aboutir à
l'accord et on l'a pas eu enfin on a eu
deux portefeuilles et ça a été une
déception immense alors ça a été vécu
comme un échec diplomatique par les
pouvoirs publics les états un l'onu et
ça a été ça a provoqué beaucoup de
déception
dans les mouvements citoyens et ça c'est
quelque chose et ensuite la mobilisation
s'est effondré dans l'année qui a suivi
il y avait des journée mondiale pour le
climat la première année après c'est un
peu marcher la deuxième année beaucoup
moins la troisième année
vous apporte t on en parlait même plus
quand on entendait george bush dire le
train de vie des américains n'est pas
négociable
alors je réagirais après je suis né
juste ça on est plusieurs parce que le
pour expliquer ce qu on a analysé après
coup c'est à dire que le fait qu'on 2
mende est une solution qui venait d'en
haut et qu'on l'ait pas l'objet le point
de tension notre mobilisation dépend des
des pouvoirs publics le et quand quand
ça disparaissait de l'agenda on avait
plus de ressort de mobilisation bon en
2012 et alors à copenhague est né un
mouvement qui s'appelle bissy qui est
une association du pays basque kibaki
est né à ce moment là avec comme enjeu
central le climat le et en 2012 on se
retrouvait dans une situation où on
avait on se sentaient orphelins d'un
réseau
qui n'existaient pas et qui ferait du
climat sa bataille centrale ou en tout
cas parce qu'il y en a qui bataille sur
le climat mais qui vont plutôt de l'
expertise du plaidoyer mais il y avait
plus de force qui mme aubry essayé de
mobiliser les citoyens sur le climat et
pour nous c'est essentiel qui est qui et
ce type d'action aussi et c'est en 2012
qu'on a imaginé organisé ce village des
alternatives en se disant ce qui empêche
la mobilisation c'est plusieurs choses
c'est que le dérèglement climatique
c'est abstrait
en tout cas la manière dont on explique
le plus souvent en plus c'est global
donc on sait pas par quel bout le
prendre c'est un palpable
et ça provoque du coup un effet de
sidération et un sentiment d'impuissance
et de résignation du coup le on a essayé
de prendre un petit peu ces blocages à
contre-pied donc faire un village des
alternatives s'était montré des
alternatives concrètes plutôt qu'à
expliquer le problème de manière
scientifique ce qui paraît abstrait un
sale et pas mais ça paraît abstrait avec
des alternatives qu'on peut goûter qu'on
peut toucher qu'on peut tester des
constructions de murs en paille des
ateliers vélos des monnaies locales etc
et
le et avec un message positif c'est à
dire parce que la chance qu'on a c'est
que non seulement les alternatives
existent mais que le type de société que
ça préfigure
résout aussi ce qui ce qui est nocif
dans notre société
même si on n'était pas en train de
dérégler le plugin aussi chalet c'est à
dire une culture consumériste une
culture de la compétition des uns contre
les autres de tous contre la nature un
rythme effréné stressant des rapports de
domination
voilà du bruit du stress etc le ces
alternatives c'est ce slogan je sait
plus d'où il est venu moins de biens
plus de liens c'est la relocalisation
sait faire plus de choses ensemble je
donne juste un exemple mais des villes
sans voitures bon bah le défi c'est de
réinventer la mobilité donc évidemment
ça provoque des réticences parce que
c'est difficile d'imaginer comment on se
passe de voiture quand tout est organisé
autour de la voiture mais quand on
imagine comment se seraient organisés
autrement sans la voiture ben on se rend
compte que ça on se rend compte et la
ccsa convoyés dans le village des
alternatives les parkings étaient
remplacés par des grands banquets géant
de produits locaux par par des jeux pour
enfants par donc c'est s'érode cc
humaniser les villes aussi c'est
redonner de la place
à l'humain aux gens à la vision aux
plantes à la nature la culture et à la
culture aussi bien sûr ah ben on a
d'autres choses en tout cas ses dépens
ça veut dire qu'on peut jouer dans la
rue ça veut dire qu'on peut s'asseoir
voilà la ville c'est terrible c'est du
bruit des bagnoles en métal qui passe
partout des klaxons la pollution
l'asthme
on est toujours dans les trottoirs entre
les murs et les bagnoles les bons voilà
donc on pense que
faire sentir donner à voir quel type de
société construit ces alternatives
peut susciter le désir chez les gens et
donc ça c'était un moteur plus tôt
plutôt que de dire aux gens on est entre
ont court à la catastrophe donc réagi c
est en voyant que ça crée cet effet de
sidération c'était de dire on ne nie pas
qu'à la catastrophe mais les solutions
existent et en plus elle dessine ce type
de société dans lequel nous on voudrait
aller même s'il y avait pas de
dérèglement climatique ça c'est la
philosophie d'alternatiba résumé et ce
village des alternatives il a réuni
douze mille personnes ce qui a été
un déclic chez chez beaucoup de monde
qui se sentaient préoccupé par le
dérèglement climatique mais qui pensait
qu'on pouvait pas mobilisé à partir de
là plein d'autres groupes de gens que
l'on connaissait pas du tout à bayonne
alors ça commençait à lille à nantes à
bordeaux et puis ensuite ça a essaimé
partout ont organisé le même type de
village alors ça se prépare sur 7 mois à
8 mois un an parce qu'il faut faire ce
travail de conviction dans tous les
réseaux associatifs dont vous financez
pour mieux vous venu alors c'est
beaucoup c'est beaucoup du système d
c'est
c'est beaucoup du bénévolat c'est
beaucoup de du bricolage de la récup
après ça dépend des villages
je vais pas esquivé la question le le le
alors nous nous jetons
les pouvoirs publics le avant le
financement se pose la question de
l'autorisation du village et ça c'est
toujours bon alors nous c'était on
existait déjà depuis quelques années à
bayonne il savait un peu à quoi qu'il
avait à faire on ne s'était pas gagné
qu'il accepte et le but c'était de pas
menacé en fait nous on était parti pour
le faire quoi qu'il arrive c'est à dire
que si ils interdisaient ont bloqué nous
mêmes ont bloqué nous mêmes les rues et
on est de toute façon une fois que tu
poses les stands que tu poses les
barnums etc les voitures et passent pas
le mais on lui a pas dit comme ça parce
que comment dire se fait pas ça peut se
faire ça peut se faire mais ça dépend
c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas de raison de
préjugés non plus de la mauvaise volonté
des gens donc on a laissé entendre que
pour nous l'enjeu du climat était
tellement important que
il fallait le faire comprendre sans que
ce soit la menace donc le il a joué le
jeu et il il a mis les moyens qu'il
fallait les barrières les trucs
lieu servi peut-être je pense pas que
c'était ça le calcul mais parce que
c'était en tout cas il ya eu aucune
ingérence de la part de la mairie sur
mettez en avant tel truc qu'on fait et
sait et on avait des désaccords
politiques importants avec la mairie sur
d'autres sujets notamment un projet de
ligne à grande vitesse la mairie ils
soutenaient nous on était content on
avait fait des actions sur la mairie qui
les avait vachement gonflé donc le bon
en fait
et ça c'est caractéristique de
de notre ligne de conduite non violente
c'est à dire que on
en juge les actions et pas les personnes
donc en face des mêmes personnes on est
capable d'être super déterminée et de
s'opposer frontalement et de poser le
conflit et 2 et 2 et même si ça suicide
de la tension voire un rapport
diplomatique en bonne et due forme non
mais d'avoir vraiment un rapport de
force à nu mais a assumé de de se fâcher
entre guillemets mais en fait on fera
pas d'attaqués personnelles le c'est
vraiment le la politique et en même
temps par exemple la même mairie
développer un projet de voie de bus en
site propre donc des voies dédiées aux
bus donc sas a suscité une levée de
boucliers des commerçants et les
automobilistes c'était impopulaire et là
on soutenait la mairie le parce que pour
nous c'était un bon projet même si
c'était un populaire même si c'était la
mairie avec laquelle on n'était pas
d'accord sur un autre projet parce que
sinon qu'il meure quelles tendances le
il s'était alors je ça a changé entre
temps et je veux pas dire de bêtises
mais c'était centriste dit ouais alors
centriste du coup c'est ubi modem et
puis en a qui sont pas encartés mais
qu'ils ont on a fini un peu leur
tendance je sais pas trop le à l'époque
ce dont je m'occupais dans cette
association s'était pas les négos avec
avec la préfecture puis j'habite est un
petit peu plus loin donc j'ai vachement
j'ai participé surtout après au
déploiement d'alternatiba sur les
territoires donc le jeu je veux pas me
tromper de non mais tu donnes qui te
paye alors en ce moment je suis
salarié de nguékokh 21 je suis à mi
temps au smic
et puis depuis février donc là j'étais
au chômage avant avant j'étais
au smic alternativa à plein temps et
encore avant la mi-temps enfin bon bref
c'est là aussi c'est un peu de la
débrouille quoi et après oui ça nous
arrive d'avoir des aides des pour des
pouvoirs publics nous notre ligne c'est
que ça ne doit avoir aucune incidence
sur notre ligne politique donc aucune
contrepartie politique qu'est ce qu'on
en parle d'une politique aucune
contrepartie politique c'est à dire que
nous on présente l'événement
on a besoin de barnum de barrières
dessous on les demande mais le
sait contre rien c'est sûr qu'on ne
changent pas le projet qu'on a présentée
et nous en général or là nous en tout
cas bissy au pays basque
on demande de l'aide mais on a un plan b
c'est à dire que si on n'a rien on
maintient quand même l'événement mais on
va mettre une plus petite scène on va
faire on va réduire les coûts on va
faire un truc un peu plus petit mais on
veut pas que ce qu'ont choisi de faire
dépendre de la décision de
des pouvoirs publics par contre on veut
pas non plus se priver des moyens qu'ont
les pouvoirs publics qui nous
permettrait de faire un événement plus
grands qui touche plus de monde qui
impulse une dynamique plus grande on
préfère avoir les sous nous plutôt que
des projets avec lesquels on ne serait
pas d'accord où la lgv et sert à quoi
donc c'est un peu cette gymnastique mais
même pas c'est à dire qu'une fois que
c'est clair
bas en ce pont on ne s'oppose pas
dilemme on a une direction une direction
ou une autre je vais revenir sur le
début de l'interview vous intéresser
tout un tas de sujets est ce que vous
êtes intéressé à la finance l'évasion
fiscale à ce système qui veut lui sur
une fonction exponentielle sur la
production monétaire des choses comme ça
bah oui assez directement alors
le début 2015
il ya un des nombreux scandales un des
nombreux scandales sur l'évasion fiscale
qui a éclaté sur la hsbc au début
février 2015 vous êtes sorti par
quelques anciens en alerte
je sais plus
je sais plus mais en tout cas c'était le
moment où on pouvait on pouvait
quantifier la somme d'argent que ça
avait permis de sortir de sortir du pays
sûr sûr sûr une certaine sur une
certaine période on tourne dès le tour
stéphanie gibout non non non parce que
là c'était la hsbc celle hsbc stéphanie
ribot oui mon doigt
c'était fini mais antoine deltour n'en
antoine deltour c'est télé luxembourg et
tout ça voilà le tour des petits pièges
promoteur your town en mai mois là
depuis jeu il y en a eu tellement
que je les confonds mais le met
d'ailleurs je vais venir moi j'y connais
rien à l'évasion fiscale
c'est super compliqué j'ai aucune
formation en économie
mais j'estime en avoir compris
l'essentiel c'est pas si compliqué que
ça et du coup j'estime en avoir compris
l'essentiel c'est à dire
les banques
organiser un système d'évasion fiscale
propose à des grandes fortunes à des
multinationales
des montages financiers pour que les
profits des activités qui sont faits un
endroit soit déclaré un autre endroit où
les régimes des impôts sont différents
etc je voulais plus trivialement ça
donne quoi parce qu'ils veulent c'est
des vols y en a certains qui proposent
un concept interprétation laisse les
banques proposent un service pour baiser
la loi locale pour faire de l'évasion
fiscale m c'est ça donc le parce qu'on
est un système qui est basé sur mon nez
un système collectif qui est basée sur
l'impôt qui finance les services
collectifs les crèches les écoles la
police les tribunaux les routes la
transition écologique les pompiers
l'armée a plein de choses avec
lesquelles on n'est pas d'accord
évidemment mais mais mais le concept eu
d'accord le concept c'est que tout le
monde participe à l'umih collective est
à la hauteur de ses moyens là le
principe est complètement renversé les
plus riches vont être ceux qui payent le
moins et faire porter la charge sur ce
qu'ils gagnent le moins et qui ont plus
de difficultés et qui sont ceux qui ont
le plus besoin des services publics
parce que celui qui est super riches il
n'a pas besoin que l'hôpital
fonctionne grâce au service public et
lui se paye les médecins les chirurgiens
dont il a besoin le don que non c'est
complètement indécent bon bref le lemay
expliquer tel truc telle somme et je
sais que ça coûte 60 à 80 milliards
d'euros par an juste aux niveaux au
niveau de la france c'est le chiffre en
tout cas avancés par le syndicat
solidaires finances publiques le jour où
il ya eu ce scandale ça nous a donné une
idée on a une agence hsbc à bayonne et
on s'est dit on va aller dans l' agence
hsbc on va leur prendre des chaises et
repartir avec les chaises les ramener
chez nous à visage découvert en plein
jour
pour faire une sorte de
deux miroirs quoi c'est à dire que nous
on va voler quelque chose pour révéler
qu'en fait c'est les voleurs salaire un
peu tordu comme ça mais vous allez au
printemps nous on a appelé ça
réquisitionnés parce que c'est ça fait
plus juridique que c'est à dire qu' il
pourrait récupérer les chaises mais il
faut qu'il faut qu'il rende l'argent
et l'histoire c'était en attendant on
garde les chaises parce qu'elles sont
plus utiles à une association qui essaie
de faire bouger les choses pour
l'intérêt général pour la justice
sociale la transition écologique que
dans une banque qui organise tout le
contraire c'est-à-dire l'injustice et
puis tous les projets qui détruisent la
planète j'ouvre une parenthèse ce légume
ce qu'ils font oui mais alors c'est
il ya des choses illégales il ya des
choses légales mais ce quelque chose en
ligue 1 et il ya des choses et
illégitime
l'apartheid c'était légal on peut
considérer que c'est est illégitime et
les gens qui luttait contre l'apartheid
entré en désobéissance civile donc là on
est dans dans la même dans le même
raisonnement on fait une action qui est
illégal mais qui nous paraît légitime
parce qu'elle va révéler une situation
d'injustice plus grande est la réelle
situation d'injustice évidemment il ya
c'est aussi un acte de défiance parce
que
ça pose
ben c'est offensif par rapport par
rapport à la hsbc de ont alors appris on
leur avait pris cet oubli fauteuil
rentrer comme ça on prend les fauteuils
on ressort ça dure deux minutes en plus
les dons qu'il appelle la police nous on
a mis la vidéo sur internet tout le
monde sait que les fauteuils sont chez
nous on l'assument et c'est ça qui est
déstabilisant aussi ce serait plus
facile d'aller réprimer quelques un café
un cambriolage à la hsbc mais ça pas du
tout le même sens politique le
et la police nous appelle
et donc ils nous connaissent un peu
quand on connaît series ont l'habitude
qu'on fasse des actions à bayonne et
dans le pays basque donc ils nous disent
c'est pendant que les ai eus au
téléphone mais globalement c'était mon
là vous avez dépassé les bornes on peut
pas vous laisser
voler le mobilier dans la banque
rendez les chieuses donc on va faire une
perquisition du local mais c'était comme
c'est vraiment gentil pour nous prévenir
ce qui fait que on s'est posé la
question de quoi faire et qu'on a décidé
de d'organiser un recel des chaises
réquisitionnée mais en les envoyant à
des personnes qui
incarne quelque chose donc on a envoyé
une chaise à patrick viveret parce que
c'est quelqu'un justement qui qui
analyse les systèmes financiers qui fait
la promotion des monnaies locales bon
qui est un discours là un discours sur
sur ce système là
deux chaises au président d'attac dont
c'est aussi le sujet la finance une
chaise au président des amis de la terre
parce que nous notre slogan c'était
l'argent pour la transition existe la
transition écologique existe il est dans
les paradis fiscaux
parce qu'on a un mouvement climat donc
on faisait le lien et puis une chaise au
syndicat solidaires finances publiques
dont c'est le boulot d'aller récupérer
les impôts
donc la police vient il nous restait
trois chaises et alors c'est il ya déjà
cette image ridicule des policiers qui
récupère les trois chaises et qui les
met dans le fourgon de police pourra les
ramener à la hsbc donc nous évidemment
on jubile parce que
la hsbc en fait anticipa que c'est
désastreux pour son image que les
policiers aillent chercher trois
fauteuils on est deux jours après le
scandale qui éclate sur le fait que tout
le monde leur reproche d'avoir
d'avoir organisé le pillage des finances
publiques donc forcément c'est
désastreux
le et la tête des policiers quand on
leur dit que les fauteuils on les a
envoyés à patrick huard et attaque un
peu un peu partout en france quoi le
donc en fait c'est stratégie non
violente et pose des dilemmes est posée
alors le dilemme des policiers après je
vais remonter au dilemme que ça pose à
la banque le dilemme des policiers c'est
que bon il en avril sont fichés 1 et
puis avait autre chose à faire que
d'aller y courir après des chaises et il
le disait un mais c'est le procureur qui
leur a dit de récupérer les chaises le
procureur apparemment il n'avait pas du
tout aimé et le donc le policier là il
se retrouve à se dire
son boulot à lui c'est d'aller récupérer
les chaises donc il est censé aller
mais nous en plus on avait imaginé que
si jamais il le faisait par exemple
patrick viveret il aurait répondu aux
policiers à mais ma chaise je les
données à edgar morin et le gard morin
aurait dit mais moi en fait les filets à
claude alphandéry un jeu de chaises
musicales qui fait qu'en plus ça met
tout le monde dans le coup ah oui parce
qu'en plus comment on a eu l'idée parce
que le policier nous avait dit attention
parce que vous vous rendez peut-être pas
compte de ce que vous avez fait mais
toutes les personnes qui ont les chaises
peuvent être poursuivis pour recel de
vol en réunion et mais pour nous c'était
génial c'est à dire que du coup on
pouvait tous se retrouver dans cette
logique de désobéissance civile et puis
si on en attrape et 1 il fallait aussi
attrapé de guerre morin claude
alphandéry patrick viveret donc ça
évidemment ça devenait infernale la
situation se retourne contre eux
le banc les policiers du coup
ils ont arrêté de chercher les chaises
quoi je sais pas si l'on fait semblant
les chercher ils ont entre un peu des
gens qui les prix de choses ils nous ont
convoqués trois fois au commissariat et
bah c'était nous on nous voit sur la
vidéo 1 alors on sentait la menace du
procureur qui disent ça va pas se passer
comme ça et cetera mais ça peut le
procurant que c'est pas ça serait
intéressant de trouver une new way
demande avec une nounou
est alors c'était en 2015 et
le
bon duc du coup ça a rien donné enfin en
terme de poursuite mais je pense qu'ils
ont vachement hésiter et et ils ont ils
ont eu raison parce que le en fait le
dilemme que ça pose à la banque
maintenant c'est soi et crie au scandale
à 10 ans c'est inacceptable il rentre
dans la banque comme ça ils nous
prennent nos fauteuils
voilà plus travailler voilà donc porté
plainte ils l'ont fait mais bon ca c il
y a aussi les histoires d'assurance tout
ça mais il ya il ya plusieurs manières
de porter plainte quand il ya porté
plainte en criant au scandale et à dire
il faut et puis porté plainte en disant
bon je sais pas trop comment ça se passe
mais le met en tout cas le ils ont ils
ont ce dilemme la soie y crie au
scandale et il cherche à activer une
répression
qui peuvent pas mener eux mêmes
soit ils font le dos rond ils font comme
si de rien n'était mais c'est en fait
ils sont perdants dans les deux cas ou
en tout cas nous on a une carte à jouer
pour exploiter la situation dans les
deux cas s'ils crient au scandale et si
on est poursuivi save a indigné les gens
de se dire mais c'est quand même pas
normal qu'un tel soient poursuivis pour
avoir pris une chaise à une banque à qui
on reproche de participer un système qui
nous coûte nos services publics quoi 60
à 80 milliards d'euros et ici ils font
rien c'est un aveu de culpabilité parce
que nous et si quelqu'un rentre
maintenant en studio et vous prend
l'écran la caméra le truc vous avez pas
considérer que c'est normal évidemment
que c'est pas normal donc si vous vous
laissez faire c'est que vous avez
quelque chose à vous reprocher quoi soit
vous avez
volé le matériel soit fin j'en sais rien
quoi donc c'est un aveu de culpabilité
le saas est une notion qui est vachement
important dans la stratégie non-violente
c'est
d'être à l'initiative est de poser un
dilemme à votre adversaire qui va être
pris de court et vous vous avez
anticiper ce que ce que vous faites donc
la hsbc elle a fait la stratégie du dos
rond
et puis c'est une action qui a inspiré
d'autres militants et petit à petit on a
monté une campagne autour de ça jusqu'à
la coop 21 c'est à dire qu'on a lancé m
avec des intellectuels des politiques
des journalistes enfin j avais pas 80
personnalités
qui ont appelé à réquisitionner 196
chaise dans les banques impliquées dans
l'évasion fiscale en sont en france
alors les pires c'était
on a cité les pires la bnp la société
générale le crédit agricole
en tant que banque française et on a
ajouté la hsbc dans la liste parce que
c'était un peu la star de l'année enfin
celle qui s'était fait prise pris la
main dans le sac et alors ça c'était sur
un rapport du ccfd terre solidaire
du coup les trois banques françaises qui
sont les pires en tout d'ailleurs un les
pires en évasion fiscale les pires en
investissement qui détruisent la planète
les pires pour l'armement et c est
le alors 187 ch est-ce parce que c'était
le nombre d'états représenté à la coop
et qu'on était toujours dense dans ce
message le l'argent pour la transition
écologique parce que ça coûte de
l'argent
et dans les paradis fiscaux et au moment
où tout le monde allait parler de climat
le il se trouve que les pays riches
traînent des pieds pour financer ce
qu'on appelle le fonds vert pour le
climat c'est à dire un fonds qui doit
permettre au pays les plus impactés par
le dérèglement climatique
de s'adapter les plus impactées et les
moins responsables du dérèglement
climatique donc c'est pas on ne demande
pas aux pays riches d'être généreux et
d'aider les pauvres pays à qui il arrive
un malheur 1 c'est nous qui avons
enclenché le dérèglement climatique et
qui sommes les moins impactés les plus
responsables et donc c'est un mécanisme
de bas justice en fait bon et les pays
riches rechigne traînent des pieds et
alors que c'était là il devait s'engager
sur
auger que le chiffre mais en tout cas
c'était c'était c'était beaucoup moins
que ce que coûte l'évasion fiscale
chaque année rien qu'au niveau européen
quand je t'ouvre une parenthèse je vous
ouvre une parenthèse
vous êtes posé la question pourquoi il y
traîner des pieds est ce que vous êtes
posé la question pourquoi il n'avait pas
un peu plus de
d'énergie pour sauver le climat dans les
banques est ce que vous êtes posé la
question
pourrait être mouvement si votre
mouvement n'était pas plus
contre-productif
que de l'évasion fiscale que maintenant
le système bancaire en place
alors faudrait que raconte une autre
histoire pour ça je finis du coup mais
en accélérant le le cette histoire de
chaises c'est que ça a multiplié les
actions il ya eu une quarantaine
d'actions de réquisition de chaises et
du coup ça a pris de l'ampleur et celle
qui était la plus visée c'était la bnb
et la bnp elle a fait l'erreur de porter
plainte et que ça aille jusque jusqu'en
justice vous avez été moi j'ai été la
première personne du coup poursuivi pour
vol en réunion et vous n'avez pas été
condamné j'ai été relaxé connexion mais
hélas on a bien vu comment la situation
s'est complètement retournée contre
contre la banque et c'est c'est comme
c'est pas anodin parce que
la bnp ils ont une armée de juristes une
armée de professionnels de la
communication et nous c'est une action
qui a coûté zéro euro on n'a pas
d'avocat on travaille avec des bouts de
ficelle
au début de l'action et mais justement
le à partir de là le piège se referme
sur eux c'est à dire que dès lors que
moi je suis poursuivi on peut appeler
eva joly avant on peut pas le mais
maintenant je suis poursuivi oui on peut
appeler le gard morin qui avait accepté
que patrick viveret lua lua lui lui file
une chaise mais là on tu vois on peut
lui dire est ce que tu peux nous
soutenir etc etc on peut mobiliser
beaucoup plus d'associations parce qu'en
fait l'injustice est révélée et
l'injustice est résumée à une situation
donc ça va cristalliser en fait
la bataille de la justice selon vos
plumes juge bien sûr et le et le point
de vue
de beaucoup de gens en tout cas on va
essayer de convaincre on va essayer de
faire partager notre point de vue le là
où on voit que il ya eu une perte de
contrôle de la bnp c'est que des
premiers des premiers échanges qu'on
avait eu entre mais avocate et les leurs
c'était qu'il comptait demander des
dommages pour préjudice commercial et
préjudice d'image donc on peut chiffrer
à des dizaines de milliers d'euros donc
là on est dans une stratégie on en prend
on tape dur dessus pour que ça dix
souhaitent tous les autres de rentrer
dans les banquets et de faire des
actions comme ça
le finalement quand il dépose des
écritures donc juste avant le procès les
avocats dans un petit peu les éléments
qui vont leur plaidoirie les éléments
qui vont utiliser etc là ils demandaient
plus qu'un euro
de dommages et intérêts cédric ouais bah
du coup symbolique enfin ils ont pas dit
que c'est symbolique mais il ya un euro
leur ligne avait changé
pourquoi parce que dans l'intervalle ça
avait vachement prix médiatiquement et
ils ont compris que l'histoire allait se
retourner contre eux c'est à dire qu'ils
allaient passer pour vraiment les
méchants de l'histoire donc là c'était
l'autre ligne c'est à dire
c'est quand même nous qui avons raison
on peut pas se faire voler on n'a rien à
se reprocher l'évasion fiscale c'est
parce que vous croyez etc mais mais bon
on va quand même demandé qu'un euro de
dommages et intérêts est-ce qu'on est
cool tu vois bien qu'ils coup voilà et
finalement le jour du procès ils sont
pas représentés au tribunal c'est à dire
que le l'avocat de la bnp rentrent même
pas alors qu'en fait des journalistes
parlent avec lui dans en dehors non
qu'on sait qu'il est venu donc moi ça me
laisse imaginer que ils ont pris la
décision de pas venir dans le tribunal
dans les dernières heures alors que
l'avocat était déjà dans le train quoi
le donc c'est dire le le manque de
contrôle
qu'ils avaient dans cette histoire
grosse mobilisation à l'extérieur plein
plein plein de choses qui se passent il
était cuit bon voilà donc ça se retourne
complètement comprenant je détaille un
peu pour montrer
comment fonctionne une stratégie
non-violente c'est à dire que on a des
moyens complètement disproportionné par
rapport à eux en termes de communication
et ses pas et pourtant l'histoire au
niveau communication se retourne contre
eux et au tribunal ça se retourne contre
eux aussi
le et pourtant ils sont plus de moyens
c'est simplement qu'on les a attirés sur
un terrain qu'ils connaissent pas
c'est nous qui avons placé le dilemme
est qu'ils aient acquis les avons attiré
dans une histoire dont il maîtrisé par
les codes ça vous a fait changer au plus
haut non je pense pas le alors du coup
j'ai maintenant j'ai une autre anecdote
on visait la société générale qui a payé
500 millions $ pour l'unité de soutien
poursuivent aux états unis et alors
il monter le dossier d'un projet de
mine de charbon de géant en australie
qui s'appelle alpha cole projet bien
juteux ouais un truc énorme nous on
appelle ça une bombe climatique
c'est-à-dire tutu développe des projets
comme ça et en fait ça réduit à néant
tous les efforts que tu fais ailleurs
parce que ça ouvre voilà en plus il
fallait construire une énorme ligne de
chemin de fer qu'elle est jusqu'à un
gros porc qu'il fallait construire aussi
mais qui était sur la barrière de corail
donc la totale c'est à dire que tu
détruis un endroit temps détruit un
autre maritime au niveau de la barrière
de corail tout ça pour mettre encore
plus de gaz à effet de serre dans
l'atmosphère pour tout le monde et on a
commencé la campagne à bayonne en visant
la société générale en leur posant
du coup c'était pas trop un dilemme
c'est un ultimatum
on leur disait le ce projet on avait
calculé pas nous mais les amis de la
terre avaient calculé que ça émettrait
1,8 milliard de tonnes de co2 dans
l'atmosphère et du coup on a annoncé à
la banque condé verserait une tonne 8 de
charbon devant leurs banques
si le moment de leur âge et il annonçait
pas qu'il se retirait de ce projet pour
montrer aux gens que pour dénoncer et
montrer aux gens que eux ils
s'apprêtaient à émettre dans
l'atmosphère un milliard de fois le tac
qu'on déposerait devant leur devant leur
devant leurs agences et donc cet
ultimatum était placé à quelques
semaines
et dans l'intervalle on faisait plein
d'action rigolote avec des costumes de
kangourou où on venait dans la banque
alors on leur apporte tout d'abord une
lettre pour leur expliquer notre
stratégie avec un boomerang donc là il
nous découvre je le sens comme tout
minutes toute petite histoire un proche
tout postulant ça marche les ensuite on
vient occuper leurs banques pour faire
une conférence donc ils sont très
embêtés il appelle la police mais ils
veulent pas l'image de la police qui
nous vire et c'est donc ils jouent la
montre donc on apporte des matelas dans
l' agence ont fait un coup de bluff on
leur fait croire qu'on va camper ici
donc du coup finalement ils nous font
expulser on a l'image qu'on veut etc et
puis le jour de l'ag c'était trop court
ils sortent pas mais en fait nous à
chaque fois en discuter avec le
directeur régional et le ton a vachement
changé c'est à dire qu'au départ ils
étaient super super vénère contre nous
super énervés contre nous steijns et
mais vous vous rendez pas compte en fait
plein de trucs bien on vient nettoyer la
plage avec une asso du coin et c'est
allah vous flinguer complètement notre
communication on n'est même pas au
courant de ce projet de mine de charbon
etc voilà et
petit à petit donc non plus demandé des
rendez-vous il accepte à la fin c'est
lui qui nous demandait un rendez-vous au
fur et à mesure que l'échéance swiss
open je veux me rappelais plus le et
il prenait des notes quand on expliquer
le changement climatique tue on sentait
que ça percute et quand même et à la fin
le dernier rendez vous il nous disait
bon
je comprends votre message je comprends
ce que vous faites je respecte votre
mode d'action moi je me sens assez
coincé parce que je
perds mon boulot aussi
si si je me mets à dire que c'est vous
qui avez raison quoi mais je ferai rien
pour vous empêcher de menez votre action
et j'ai tous les jours au téléphone la
direction nationale pour leur dire que
vous allez le faire donc c'était devenu
ce qu'on appelle un au moins un allié
passif quelqu'un qui est censé être
notre opposant et qui se neutralisent je
prends des fois ils peuvent même devenir
nos alliés mais évidemment ils prennent
plus de risques c'est comme les danseurs
l'alertent
et on a fini par gagner cette campagne
le plus tard on a dit puisque c'est ça
puisque vous n'avez pas arrêté toute
l'année 2015 qui est l'année de la coque
d'un terrain où tout le monde va parler
climat ont et qui va devenir
potentiellement progressivement une
mobilisation internationale on va dire
que l'ennemi numéro un du climat c'est
la société générale on finira par une
marche aux champs elysées entre 21h ans
de la société générale pendant la coop
21 le cauchemar voilà et ils ont reçu
cette lettre et ils nous ont pas pris au
sérieux au début et on a commencé les
premières actions qui a annoncé sa deux
jours après ils ont dit on se retire du
projet et un contexte de retard tout ça
finalement c'était moins bien que ce
qu'on pensait on se retire et mais il
rajoute merci de prévenir vos réseaux
qu'on se retire c'est à la phrase qui
qui montre que c'est pas le contexte de
retard du projet la vraie raison c'est
que le projet était plus assumable est
géré discuté avec le directeur régional
et je voulais savoir qu'est ce qui
s'était passé pourquoi ils ont changé
d'avis utilisé est-ce que c'est
justement là la menace le fait que
c'est la menace était suffisante sur
pour l'heure comme et il m'a dit papa
seulement ils me disent et c'est le
directeur national qui a vachement
insisté auprès du directeur
international qui a dit faut absolument
arrêter ce projet c'est pas possible
mais moi ce qui m'intéressait dans ce
cas là pourquoi le directeur national
insisté à ce point et il me dit lui
aussi a des enfants
donc ma conclusion c'est que
tu es et eilat atteindre quelque chose
d'autre qui est caractéristique de la
non violence c'est à dire c'est c'est un
jeu entre le la force de la contrainte
et la force de la persuasion tutu doit
perturber les choses pour pouvoir faire
passer un message que les gens sont pas
disposés à écouter ou tu ne fais pas
partie de leurs interlocuteurs
donc ils coûtent pas le et eux reçoivent
pas en réunion et c'est le dû perturber
les choses pour pouvoir passer ce
message mais tu perturbe les choses tout
en respectant les personnes pour
qu'elles puissent quand même rester à
l'écouté pour revenir à l'ecoute qui est
des conditions de dialogue qu'ils
puissent être établies ou maintenus et
faire aussi le travail de persuasion le
pompon monde pour moi c'est super
important et alors ce que m'a dit le
directeur régional il me disait bon pour
moi c'est un grand soulagement qu'on
soit sorti de ce projet parce que même
dans l'agencé terrasse à créer un vrai
malaise les gens comprenaient pas
pourquoi la société générale faisait un
projet comme ça c'est pas leur métier
enfin au niveau régional section de +
vul oui non mais eux c'est de faire des
prêts pour des voitures des maisons ses
deux soeurs des chemins l'austisme ou
qui payent des retraites c'est des
choses comme ça donc j'ai révélation ce
que je veux dire c'est que eux s'étaient
pas les décisionnaires d'aller flinguer
la planète faire d'aider des projets de
charbon etc mais en fait il se sentait
pas en phase avec sa forte que le terol
mais non c'est des alliés potentiels
c'est à dire que justement comment les a
convaincus bon on se retrouve dans une
le cul entre deux chaises mais ce
malaise dans la société générale a
participé du changement de décision au
sommet
bon on fait un petit tour sur le grill
ouais bon tu proposes quoi pour changer
le système au niveau de l'emploi au
niveau de la finance au niveau de la
monnaie au niveau de la croissance parce
que tu es pour la croissance pour la
croissance
ariane scotia estime encore le temps
est-ce que tu prônes le fait d'éviter
une croissance exponentielle de la
démographie ce que
cette chose comme ça bon je commence à
piocher et puis tu le
le bon la croissance c
je la croissance exponentielle
évidemment non alors tu sais comment ça
se passe je vais couper 25 fois ouais
d'accord et on va commencer à entrer
dans le vif du sujet qu'est-ce qui se
passe si le système financier rentrent
en décroissance qu'est ce qui se passe
dans une population quand la
consommation énergétique de cette
population rentrer en plateau ou
s'inverse qu'est ce qui se passe mais
apparemment il se passe ça vachement des
règlements et c'est
l'expression de ma grand-mère en asie
quand il n'y a plus de foin dans les
airs at il dit les chevaux sous bat
ouais mais bon alors ça veut dire que
oui mais dans ce cas là ça veut dire que
il faut continuer de foncer dans le mur
sinon on va se prendre le mur quoi j'ai
position du monde que si ce poste non je
ne sais pas ce qui se passe mais ce que
ce que je ce que je lis et dans ta
question c'est que
le en fait si
si
si on fait rentrer le système dans la
décroissance ça va provoquer les
pénuries le chaos et c'est le mais en
fait ça veut dire du coupon pour que tu
fus pas des flics mais ça veut dire que
même moi je veux pas le chaos je veux
pas que les gens se battent je veux pas
je veux pas la pénurie mais elle est
promise aussi par ce système est aussi
par la croissance donc le truc c'est le
système qui va pas il faut le faire
marcher ni à l'endroit ni à l'envers
c'est il faut champ il faut changer de
système donc d'abord la croissance c'est
un
la croissance c'est pour moi c'est un
dogme ça relève d'une croyance de croire
qu on peut toujours faire de la
croissance de la croissance et je pense
que c'est
c'est un dogme c'est à dire une
idéologie c'est à dire un
raisonnement qui s'appuie sur une idée
fondamentale qu'on peut pas remettre en
question on part du principe qu'il faut
toujours de la croissance et à partir de
là on se pose les autres questions le ce
qu'on appelle les objecteurs de
croissance sont ceux justement qui vont
remettre en question cette première idée
bon moi je suis sensible à leur
raisonnement et jeu
effectivement je pense qu'ils ont raison
parce que le système de croissance
exponentielle fait qu'on produit de plus
en plus mais en fait on n'est pas de
plus en plus heureux on explose les
ressources ont des règles de plus en
plus tout vu ou conseillers on a quand
même des pénuries mais on concentre le
pouvoir
oui alors oui oui mais alors je ne sais
pas quel point scellier etc on pourrait
qu'on pourrait concentrer le pouvoir
sans sens tu vois quand on était dans
des dans des systèmes de royalistes par
exemple l'hôtel et j'imagine que le
pouvoir était concentré et puis on
n'était pas forcément dans une logique
de croissance exponentielle mais est
soucié de conduite de guérir c'est vrai
et bon en tout cas le c'est
bon mais je réponds parce que tu m'a
posé la question
moi je suis parce qu'on te tue réponse
cette croissance est effectivement je
pense qu'il faut c'est une idéologie une
manière de penser une manière de voir le
monde et il faut sortir de ça il faut il
faut se rendre compte que on peut
s'épanouir en tant qu'être humain
avoir des relations humaines faire de la
reproduire des choses sur notre
territoire mais dans les limites de la
planète bah en fait façon maintenant la
limite à laquelle on est
au-delà de la question philosophique de
est-ce qu'il faut toujours plus et c est
ce que ça nous rend heureux c'est que là
on est confronté aux limites physiques
de la planète donc 2e etc matic
mathématiquement impossible une
croissance une croissance infinie est
donc oui ça pose un gros problème si on
va dans l'espace qu'on attrape des
astéroïdes et couchant toute l'année
mais moi je suis pour que les gens qui
sont pour une croissance infinie dans
l'espace et qui nous laisse la planète
sont combles ou voilà comme ils veulent
qu on dise ce qu'ils veulent ils peuvent
aller sur mars et ses affaires
terraformer la planète mars et faire des
gaz de schiste sur la planète mars et
dramé parce que moi je pense qu'on a une
seule planète donc ceux qui veulent
tenter l'aventuré ailleurs libre à vous
de le faire mais cette planète je pense
qu'il faut
la préserver t'es pas posé la question
s'il avait besoin de la vie d'esclave
pour construire la petite fusée il avait
peut-être besoin du gharb et donc il
avait fait deux autres d'une armée de
banque pour faire de l'évasion fiscale
pour concentrer un peu leur peau ou
consultent faire un réseau bio
pyramidale pour pouvoir se construire
leur petit ouais c'est vrai qu'il ya
moyen de cramer la planète en partant de
la planète ça vaudrait l'éviter
mais bon qu'est ce que tu proposes
économique moindre économiquement moi il
ya quelque chose que j'ai trouvé bien au
pays basque alors je parle beaucoup du
pays basque évidemment c c'est un pays
magnifique et c'est là-bas que j'habite
donc je j'ai suivi plus de choses on a
lancé une monnaie locale qui marchent
hyper bien qu'ils s'appellent locaux
c'est
l'une des ses devenue une des deux
premières monnaies locales européennes
donc au ca pas encore complètement
révolutionné l'économie du pays basque
mais on est quand même un peu sorti de
la niche dans laquelle trop souvent on
reste enfermé dans des monnaies locales
pourquoi c'est intéressant une monnaie
locale
comment ça fonctionne c'est une monnaie
qui ne peut circuler que dans un
territoire donné donc mécaniquement ça
ça sert la relocalisation de l'économie
c'est à dire que les produits la monnaie
c'est un produit c'est une manière de de
quantifier les échanges le cardo non vie
continue et le le donc la relocalisation
c'est une solution écologique parce que
le une partie de notre problème et et
une grande partie de notre problème
vient du fait que on a fait le grand
déménagement du monde quoi on produit un
truc là-bas pour l'amener ici pour le
transformer encore ailleurs le consommer
machin envoyer encore les déchets chez
les autres et c'est le donc de
relocaliser ça permet à la fois
d'émettre moins de gaz à effet de serre
parce qu'on mange ce qu'on produit sur
place il ya pas les camions les bateaux
les avions les frigos et sert à ça
permet aussi d'être plus en lien avec
les gens qu'ils font donc ça veut dire
que justement on met pas en esclavage
d'autres paysans dans d'autres endroits
ont fait pas travailler des enfants en
chine machin sera parce que c'est chez
nous alors on décide de le faire chez
nous mais évidemment chez nous on va pas
vouloir que les enfants travaillent et
que et c est ce qui est normal j'ai
entendu des vieux
leu leu
donc mécaniquement c'est un outil de
localisation mais c'est plus que ça
parce que la mise en place de la monnaie
locale et une phase décisive avant qu'on
la mette en place ce qui a été et ce qui
a été fait c'est un processus où on a
défini les critères des acteurs
économiques du territoire qui pourrait
utiliser la monnaie locale donc c'est
pas simplement que c'est sur le
territoire c'est que ça doit répondre à
certains critères on a défini des
critères écologiques des critères
sociaux de justice sociale
le et des critères aussi culturelle au
niveau au niveau du pays basque le
processus même de définir les critères
est important parce que ça veut dire
qu'on réunit autour de la table des
acteurs qui ont une activité
sur le territoire et donc il ya déjà une
une réflexion collective sur le type
d'économie qu'on veut sur le territoire
est ce qu'on va favoriser avec la
monnaie locale donc ça veut dire qu'on
est dans la réappropriation
de l'économie et qu'on lui donne une
direction parce que le problème aussi de
cette financiarisation de l'économie et
le capitalisme c'est en à boutons
l'impression que c'est elle les humains
au service de l'économie que l'économie
au service des humains je n'étais pas
capable de comprendre le cap ou qui ou
que tu n'es pas capable de comprendre le
cap qui est déjà pris ouais et en tout
cas on n'a pas l'impression que ça
marche comme
pour nous aider quoi tu penses que la
peur classe est devenu mégalomane
sociopathe avec une pathologie mentale
poussant toujours vers l'extrême alors
les sociopathes juste après
juste après cette monnaie locale qui
fait que ensuite tut tut tut tut
enclenche un cercle un cercle vertueux
c'est à dire que non seulement ça
relocalise mais ça favorise ce que tu
considères est bon pour le territoire
l'écologie les gens qui vivent ici donc
ça te redonne l'économie de retard donne
un pouvoir de transformation de ton
territoire pour moi c'est l'antithèse de
l'économie néolibérale
ou c'est tout le contraire c'est à dire
l'argent s'échapper il est stocké et le
et bon voilà alors plutôt qu'une soizic
il ya d'autres choses à dire de la
monnaie locale mais on a d'autres sujets
non je ne suis pas du tout un théoricien
de l'économie gélules à une bd qui avait
fait qu'elle est c'est vachement parler
d'elle economics et puis un autre truc
j'ai essayé de m'y intéresser en disant
je suis vraiment nous comprend rien en
économie et en plus c'est aussi parce
que je passais en procès pour évasion
fiscale et je faisais du service qu'ils
n'ont jeu passées en procès pour avoir
dénoncer l'évasion fiscale pardon pour
avoir donc procès pour vol en réunion
pour avoir réquisitionné des chaises et
du coup mais je connaissais pas plus le
sujet que ce à quoi je dis pas que
j'avais juste ton bon sens
ouais mais c'est mais je trouve que
c'est justement les actions les plus
pédagogiques c'est-à-dire en une action
les gens comprennent qu'il ya un truc
qui cloche et justement tes papiers dans
le débat mais qu'est ce qui se passe si
justement les questions personne que tu
me poses les plus canons machin etc
l'agencé comme je ne sais pas c'est que
je dois rien y comprendre donc c'est
finalement les puissants qu'ils doivent
avoir raison non le ses actions simples
ça permet aussi aux gens de de
ouais enfin ne pas se laisser berner de
dire ouais c'est vrai que c'est eux qui
nous volent le
le donc non donc du coup j'ai bûché
l'économie décidément c'est pas mon truc
qui comprend rien le le mais la monnaie
mais la monnaie locale ouais mais bon ça
doit pas être mon truc mais la monnaie
locale j'ai compris toi
le alors est-ce que c'est des
sociopathes c'est une question que je me
pose pas ce que le c'est absurde ce
qu'on fait c'est à dire que bon bien sûr
on se dit là les riches ils
s'enrichissent les pauvres
s'appauvrissent donc les riches ont un
intérêt à s'enrichir etc bon d'abord moi
je pense que je pense pas qu'ils on
puisse être heureux
à accentuer un système qui rend les
autres malheureux peut-être que des gens
s'imaginent être heureux mais j'ai en
tout cas j'ai vraiment dû je pense pas
qu'il soit heureux quand je n'arrive pas
à concevoir qu'on puisse être heureux
marchant sur notre deux jours eh non je
pense que les gens croient être heureux
comme ça je pense qu'ils savent pas ce
que c'est le bonheur ou qui sont malades
ouais ouais ouais aussi bon après je
pense que c'est vachement liés à des
[Musique]
ad
tu vis on vit dans des mondes un peu
différent les uns les autres et les
super riches qui vivent avec des super
riches
donc on leur ouvre les portes quand il
passe il tu vois c'est pas le même monde
que nous quoi j'avais jamais vu un truc
comme ça alors voilà philanthropie
bah ouais
alors
justement moi je pense que
je pense que tout le monde est capable
d'être bienveillant
et quelques je pense que quelqu'un qui
est son pote au logis ouais alors
évidemment appris à des choses plus
spécifique avec faut soit les
pathologies mais le nom j'écoutais la
radio la même les les les psychopathes
ou les sociopathes je sais plus fins eux
les timbres et les criminels qui dont on
dit ils ne ressentent aucune émotion et
c'est pour ça qu'ils peuvent aller
découper les gens tué tout le monde et
c'est parce qu'en fait ça l'est
ça leur fait rien ils ont fait ils ont
fait une
expérience avec des gens qui sont en
prison et qui ont fait de ce genre de
crime et qui sont alors je sais plus si
c'est sociopathe ou psychopathe est le
terme exact
et il leur montrait des images il avait
des des capteurs là pour voir si ça
activer les zones de l'empathie il leur
montrait des images de gens qui
souffrent et puis ils vont y avait rien
qui s'activent et
il en était un bébé chien non non non
ils sont pas plus sensible pour les
bébés chiens en général justement les
les personnes se sont souvent entraînés
à torturer les animaux avant d'ensuite
d'aller torture et les humains et
le j'ai entendu ça plusieurs fois le et
après il est ce qui faisait l'expérience
leur dauphin l'expérience passée comme
ça qu'il faut dire mais leur demander et
essayer de ressentir quelque chose par
rapport par rapport à ce que à ce que
vous voyez est là ça s'active et
c'est à dire que et donc je suis plus
que l'émission c'était là sur ce que
sera un truc sur france inter de la tête
au carré ou comme ça et là personne
disait on à l'hypothèse qu'on en déduit
c'est que les gens normaux entre
guillemets ont plutôt une empathie une
empathie par défaut et donc que vont
vite et ce qui explique la contagion
émotionnelle et que quand quelqu'un est
triste bas et qu'on comprend ce qui lui
arrivera en nous aussi on va ressortir
de la tristesse
et que on a un travail à faire pour des
fois on a besoin de faire un travail de
distanciation pour aider quelqu'un il
faut pas non plus être il faut être dans
l'empathie il faut pas être trop dans le
mimétisme émotionnel sinon toi aussi tu
te retrouves voilà en bref et eux c'est
le contraire par défaut c'est
l'hypothèse qu'ils ont tiré par défaut
ils ressentent rien mais ils sont
capables de ressentir d'une manière
générale je m'appuie pas sur cette cette
expérience mais ça m'a fait penser
je pense que tout le monde est capable
d'être bienveillant je pense que tout le
monde a bon fond et je pense qu'il ya là
quelque chose est perverti quand
quelqu'un
est machiavélique quand quelqu'un aime
faire souffrir les genres et non je
pense qu'un truc qui déconne et je pense
aussi d'abord que quelqu'un qui est
violent c'est quelqu'un qui souffre je
pense que quelqu'un qui est méchant
c'est quelqu'un qui est malheureux et du
coup je pense qu'il ya toujours quelque
chose à réconcilier à réparer et à
remettre en route qui fait que des gens
peuvent
peuvent se remettre en lien avec les
autres et moi il me semble que la voie
d'épanouissement
et évidente naturel chez les humains on
est une espèce social biologiquement
couple honte voilà c'est d'être en
empathie avec les autres c'est
je pense que c'est assez in et qu'on ait
le souci de l'intérêt général et
aujourd'hui on est dans une société qui
a un individu qui a individualiser les
choses et on y va du coup s'il ya une
pathologie je pense qu'elle est
collective on a une et cette maladie
s'appelle l'individualisme ça ça fait
tous partir en vrille et 12 mai mais
scellier scellier du coup
surtout qu'à la fin personne n'y trouve
son compte puisqu'on vous dit la planète
de tout le monde l'avenir des enfants de
chacun et que comme je disais je pense
qu'être dans l'opulence matérielle en
plus je voyais un reportage là ils
avaient tous des lubies fallait que la
piscine soit chauffée au demi degré près
le thé pareil le truc mais pour moi
c'est des symptômes de quelqu'un qui est
malade c'est si tu peux pas t'habituer à
une eau un peu plus froid dans la vie
c'est ça la lisez les trucs qui change
le thé ça change c'est pas toujours le
même c'est pas toujours le truc non
c'était fait toujours que ce soit pile
poil dans tu parles du bio matériel mais
est ce que tu penses ou si un truc qui
veut concentrer le pouvoir
mais pour moi c'est maladif bon ben je
sais pas bon apparemment
on dit que le pouvoir corrompt un truc
comme ça les salaires vrai ça veut pas
dire que c'est vrai pour tout le monde
veut espérer qu'il ya des gens qui
peuvent par exemple quelqu'un qui qui
m'a beaucoup inspiré et c'est marrant
parce que bon moi je suis vraiment dans
la culture de la non violence c'est
thomas sankara qui commence qui commence
son histoire par un coup d'état donc la
violence
les armes en tout cas le kir militaire
est qui qui fait un coup d'état
je réfléchis on conseille notre
communauté de les écouter ce discours
sur internet ses salutations si les
francophones il parle français donc du
coup c'est vraiment génial c'est très
très fan et alors ce qui est
impressionnant c'est que il va faire
dans les années 80 dans un pays
d'afrique où les gens vraiment du mal à
se nourrir ou il ya un manque
d'infrastructures bon voilà
un programme super en avance sur son
temps c'est à dire bon bien sûr de
justice sociale alors tous les ministres
et avait l'âme la même voiture c'est des
petites 4l tout le monde était en
seconde classe quand il devait prendre
l'avion
il disait en première classe en 2ème
classe on arrive à la même heure donc on
va pas payer plus il y avait vraiment
les ministres doivent prendre un minimum
d'argent dont il était vraiment pour le
peuple quoi vous le but et il a way à la
fin bon et mais il a mis aussi en place
des programmes de reforestation donc ils
avaient une conscience écologique faut
le saluer dans les années 80 quand même
tout le monde l'avait pas il mettait des
programmes en place pour le les droits
des femmes le donc là aussi je veux dire
nous on a mis tous cette année tu vois
je dis pas qu'ils étaient en avance sur
mis tout misé clairement il était en
avance sur son temps sur pam sur pas mal
de choses donc forcément ça m'interroge
vachement parce que pour moi tout ça je
l'assimilé plutôt à le programme
constructif d'une stratégie non-violente
quoi sauf qu'il l'a pris par par les
armes et il était pour le désarmement il
a un discours magnifique
monsieur plus éloignées où l'espèce
d'oignies de l'afrique là où il dit moi
je suis l'armée parce que tout le monde
autour de moi et remet mais il dit ces
armes c'est les occidentaux qu'ils nous
les vendent d'essai pour constituer
entre nous donc nous les africains on
doit se désarmer c'était génial parce
qu'en plus ils étaient super jeunes ils
avaient une vingtaine d'années il
s'adressait à des chefs d'africains qui
sont des dictateurs qui ont qui sont
super vieux ça fait des décennies qui
sont au pouvoir donc il y avait vraiment
un il avait le sens de l'humour donc
et bien sûr bon il a été assassiné
effectivement par quelqu'un qui est
ensuite resté au pouvoir pendant les
décennies
je sais plus pourquoi je parlais de
thomas sankara
ça fait toujours du bien ouais mais
voilà on n'a pas besoin d'avoir une
raison particulière pour penser aux
questions internet
alors que pensez-vous des black blocks
bon c'est
je pense j'ai cru comprendre que ce
n'était pas un groupe constitué c'est à
dire c'est plutôt une tactique donc les
gens s'y greffent
donc déjà ça doit être analysée d'une
manière particulière si ça c'est pas un
groupe qui fait des réunions qui décide
il ya cette manif est ce que on y vient
en mode black block ou pas et c'est donc
bah ça ça change mon opinion déjà sur
sur le phénomène s'organise ya quand
même première de cordée il commence à
réfléchir à comment c'est à dire des
bouquins chimie commence à dire des
bouquins mais
il arrive que moscou ait mais parce que
oui oui mais le plongeon dans ne te
plains mais ok mais je le vois en tout
cas plus comme une organisation
informelle bien sûr que tu peux toujours
tes à l'heure actuelle tout échange des
infos facilement
le mode opératoire se se capte
facilement donc t'as pas besoin de faire
des réunions pour le faire quoi mais
bon moi je pense que c'est
contreproductif spectre bas le en tout
cas je n'ai pas mon énergie à essayer d
empêcher de faire ça à les dénoncer à
dire voyez que mme hachem et que tu leur
ton âme un nom mais en fait si tu veux
tu vous le dire je dis qu'ils lisent et
non moi je veux radicaliser des gens
mais on le sent on pourra définir ce
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
le très intéressant tu me saoules coutu
ok le non mais les black blocks parce
que bon évidemment moi qui ai cité
plusieurs fois le mot non violence
depuis le début
le jeu c'est que ces dépositions qui
suscite des polémiques dans le milieu
militant dans le milieu politique plus
d'un millier militants quand même
moi je pense que cette tactique des
black blocs elle est contreproductive
parce que je l'enjeu c'est transformer
le système donc là il n'y a pas doute
qu'on est sur un mode d'action qui
s'attaque aux
aux emblèmes du capitalisme donc qui
délivre un message anti capitaliste a et
si la question est ce qu'on est contre
le capitalisme suis d'accord le est-ce
que d'aller casser un mcdo de balancer
des trucs sur les flics et cetera et
cetera ça transforme le système je pense
pas et très peu et par contre ce que je
vois c'est que ça donne au pouvoir en
place un moyen de justifier sa
répression
pour moi c'est ça le problème je ne dis
pas que le jeu ne dis pas que là la
violences des black blocks il faudrait
définir ce qu'est la violence cassé une
vitrine du que la vitrine souffre pas on
pourrait débattre ce que ces violents
coups pas violents j'étais quelque chose
sur les policiers déjà si c'est une arme
qui peut blesser bon pour moi ça entre
dans la catégorie des actions violentes
si la question est est-ce que c'est
aussi violent que
le que ce que fait le gouvernement non
mais ça veut pas dire c'est pas violent
ça veut pas dire que ça n'a pas
le même danger le même caractère
incontrôlable cas qu'à la violence ça
veut pas dire que c'est c'est plus
efficace qu'une aucune violence mais
légitime donc dû monter plus ou moins
des plus jeunes homos violent qu'un bug
beloteurs non mais moi j'essaie de ne
pas être violent thème comment po
système parce que là mais dangereux d'un
bloc moi je pense que la stratégie
non-violente
peut déstabiliser le système beaucoup
plus efficacement que la stratégie
violente après il suffit pas dire tiens
on est non violent et puis on fait
n'importe quoi et ça va marcher ce n'est
pas de la magie il faut trouver les
failles du système il faut mettre en
place ce que j'ai dit tout à leur poser
des dilemmes prend l'initiative les
prendre de court c'est pas tiens les
gens sont violents moi je fais rien et
puis comme par magie la situation va se
retourner contre non je pense que c'est
adapté ce contexte du moins des
principes de non violence est ce que
c'est adopter un autre contexte
oui moi je pense parce que justement
parce que le pouvoir en place utilise la
violence
le sait ce que je crois que c'est c'est
jean charest qui disait alors moi je ne
dirais pas comme ça je veux pas être
quitté jinsha un théoricien de la non
violence le de la stratégie non violente
alors je le cite je veux pas moi même je
serai pas seulement mais la formule est
bonne il faut être idiot pour choisir
les fusils quand c'est l'adversaire qui
a tous les fusils on est sur cette
notion de terrain
si tu veux battre son adversaire il faut
la mener sur le terrain où il est moins
fort que toi sur la violence c'est là où
il est le plus fort mais enfin bien sûr
eux ils ont appuyé sur un bouton pour
avoir le nombre qui veulent de gendarmes
mobiles ils choisissent le type de
grenade qui veulent envoyer canons à eau
pas canon à eau blindés pas blindé saisi
les ont dans les hangars 1 donc ils ont
juste à choisir de payer pour ça hein et
oui bien sûr donc choisir la violence je
dis pas qu'il n'ya pas en fait voilà ce
que je veux dire je respecte
la colère qui s'exprime à travers
à travers l'action des black blocks je
pense que cette colère est saine parce
que je pense que ce monde doit nous
mettre en colère et que la colère c'est
un point de départ est que quand tu
utilise ta colère pour être violent je
pense que tu tombe dans le piège
qui a été tendu par le par le pouvoir ou
en tout cas que le pouvoir
instrumentalise très très facilement
parce qu'il a beaucoup l'habitude de le
faire
le mais la colère moi je suis en colère
donc c'est là où tu veux radicaliser les
gens
justement pas forcément mais oui mais en
tout cas la colère je pense qu'elle est
plus efficace quand elle est canalisé en
stratégie non violente mais en tout cas
j'ai plus d'espoir quand je vois déjà en
colère que quand je vois des gens
indifférents je suis résigné
6 mais l'indifférence et le pire parce
que la résignation tu as quand même cédé
à quelque chose mais t'avais l'élan
premier l'indifférence c'est ce qui me
désespère le plus les gens s'en foutent
les gens dorment dans la rue on s'en
fout ça leur fait rien mais je sais pas
combien ils sont si ça leur fait
vraiment rien mais en tout cas là c'est
compliqué parce que sur quoi tu sur quoi
tu t'appuies pour
pour mettre ces gens en mouvement la
résignation tu peux t'appuyer sur sur ce
qui leur a fait perdre espoir la colère
tu peux t'appuyer dessus et et tu es tu
peut la transformer l'indifférence et le
pire c'est c'est je vois pas qu'est ce
que tu as à exploiter dans la différence
cette atonie émotionnel autre question
d'internet contexte différent que les
batailles menées par dont 10 où martin
luther king à ton avis mais c'est
évident le
mais c'est marrant parce que mende il
avait dit lui-même à la fin de sa vie il
avait dit je compare bon il a eu une
longue vie il s'est fait assassiner à
presque 80 ans je crois
il sait des décennies de stratégie non
violente qui la menait donc c'est
vraiment à la fois un pionnier est une
référence qui reste actuelle dans son
caractère vraiment complet c'est à dire
qu'il nous donne un exemple de lutte non
violente qui
qui reste très intéressante à étudier
mais lui-même à la fin de sa vie disait
je compare ce que j'ai fait
à l'électricité autant d'edison une
invention qu'il faut perfectionner le le
et bien sûr la stratégie non violente ça
commence par des questions ça commence
par où sont les failles quelles sont nos
faiblesses quelles sont nos forces
quelles sont les forces et les
faiblesses de l'adversaire
qu'est-ce qui va révéler les
contradictions chez l'adversaire qu'est
ce qui va modifier la perception par
l'opinion publique qu'est ce qui va
faire changer le comportement des gens
donc c'est absurde de ce serait absurde
de prendre une stratégie et de vouloir
la calquer alors mais je prends un
exemple absurde quelque chose qui a été
décisif dans la stratégie de dandy
c'était ce que la marche du sel le sel
était axé par les anglais le c'était
fondamental pour les indiens parce que
ça servait à la conservation des
aliments by pasky salle leur nourriture
et c'était essentiel pour l' empire
britannique au niveau économique entre
autres un mais c'était c'était un pilier
important donc il y avait une taxe et
l'interdiction aux indiens de fabriquer
leur propre c'est laure c'était une
activité traditionnelle il faisait leur
salle ils fabriquent et le recel gandhi
a trouvé une bonne idée il a fait une
marche il allait jusqu'à l'océan indien
je crois il a ramassé est bon là il ya
du sel il ya des dépôts de sel il a
ramassé une poignée de salies il y avait
toute une une campagne autour de ça
c'est à dire que les autorités il ya
plein de gens qui l'ont rejoint dans la
marche ça avait créé une tension et il
s'est fait arrêter moment il a où il a
ramassé le sel ça a été un moment où il
ya vraiment eu une grosse faille ensuite
on considère a posteriori que même si
l'indépendance a été obtenue plus tard à
était devenu irrémédiable à partir de ce
moment là je développe pas mais c'est
pour dire que moi si je me dis tiens le
gouvernement m'embête je vais aller
ramasser une poignée de sel sur l'océan
atlantique s'est évidemment que ça
marche pas je veux dire c'est pas c'est
pas la même situation bien sûr que le il
faut toujours on commence toujours par
analyser le contexte et les rapports de
force et les rapports de confiance
la radicalisation la radicalisation de
traîneau parce que moi je suis super
gêné par la radicalisation quand on lit
tout court on pense aux islamistes et ça
veut rien dire c'est à dire
le mot radical il vient de racine est-ce
que tu connais est ce que tu connais sur
le fameux speech sur internet d'un film
qui est à you want you to get made
on est happé ça sur internet c'est une
petite vidéo qui dure 4 minutes par
match de l'année
le
le sens premier de radical c'est à la
racine c'est normal qu'on développe
après d'autres sens des mots mais faut
qu'il soit quand même précis le moi je
je je me considère radical dans le sens
où les efforts que je fais dans mon
militantisme vise un changement radical
du système médical ou extrême non
radicale c'est à dire que ce que je veux
transformer dans ce système c'est pas
les apparences c'est pas la marge c'est
pas par exemple la croissance mais verte
ça c'est pas radical parce que justement
on remet pas en cause quelque chose qui
est à la racine du système le la
transformation radicale du système c'est
justement remettre en cause ce qu'il ya
de fondamental salir le consumérisme la
compétition la croissance le
matérialisme des choses comme ça le la
violence la violence ça fait partie de
l'idéologie dominante
le
le donc pour moi une action radicale et
une action qui réussit à transformer les
choses de manière radicale en profondeur
ou en tout cas qui cherche qui cherchent
à le faire moi c'est le sens que je
donne aux mots radical alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est que au tout début
disais il ya vait alternatiba qui
faisait des alternatives j'ai pas
développé actions non violentes comme
21e il ce mouvement développe plutôt les
actions d'opposition d'interposition des
désobéissances civiles
et et il ya souvent il ya eu en tout cas
au début un débat dans l'alternative
assurée ce qu'il faut faire de l'action
non-violente d'opposition et d2 et
obéissance ou pas on est né sur un
mouvement positif
avec un message d'espoir c'est ça qui
fait venir les gens et il ya des il ya
des personnes qui nous disait qu'il y
avait des personnes dont moi qui dit il
faut marcher sur les deux jambes les
alternatives et l'opposition moi et
d'autres et d'autres qui disent aimer
vous y pensez pas vous y pensez le
la désobéissance va être perçu comme
quelque chose de contestataires de
négatif par par par l'opinion publique
et il va détruire d'un autre côté ce
qu'on est en train de construire par par
les alternatives moi je crois au
contraire que les deux se se nourrissent
parce que faire des alternatives et
faire que des alternatives et dire c'est
formidable on s'est mis au vélo on mange
des produits locaux notre énergie est
produite de manière renouvelable qui ont
fait les économies d'énergie etc on fait
de la récup de la réparation bon le mais
pendant ce temps taddéï à des
multinationales qui sont en train de
tout détruire et qui sont en train
d'exploiter tout le pétrole qui sont en
train de de nous enferré dans l'impasse
du nucléaire qui sont en train
d'inventer des trucs en géo ingénierie
qui vont nous sauter à la figure et c
est du coup
et les climatologues nous disons la cinq
ou dix ans où on a encore prise sur les
leviers de transformation
principaux du système il faudra
continuer à batailler après mais les
marges de manoeuvre les plus importants
tels sont les cinq à dix ans qui
viennent donc en même temps qu'on
développe les alternatives il faut
empêcher ces grandes multinationales de
détruire parce que sinon
tu nous les alternatives qu'on construit
avec les alternatives va se faire
balayer par le dérèglement climatique
qu'on n'aura pas réussi à endiguer au
niveau global si on stoppe pas
cessé puissance de destruction et l'
inverse c'est vrai c'est à dire que
s'opposer s'opposer à total s'opposer
harry va s'opposer à monsanto mais si tu
proposes rien comme alternative on est
dans quelque chose des stériles mais
beaucoup de gens comprennent ça ne dit
pas que ceux qui s'opposent à total
monsanto et cetera l'ont pas compris
et on a toujours quelque chose à
proposer à la place et c'est là où quand
même l'opinion publique qui est pas
forcément décider elle va entendre
différemment un discours d'opposition
s'il ya une proposition alternative
qu'un discours d'opposition points on
arrête la voiture point bas mais c'est
compliqué pour les gens d'imaginer
qu'est ce que ça veut dire on arrête la
voiture mais on a eu notre mobilité un
autre rapport à la vitesse autant à
proposer une société organisée dit non
bon bah là ça peut se discuter je veux
des enfants
jeux en tout cas je sais ça me pose
vraiment ça me pose vraiment une
question grave
parce que j'ai du mal à parce que je ne
sais pas comment ça va se passer les
ouais j'ai une copine vous disant fier
way et juin est allé un peu plus jeune
que moi elle a 30 31 32 et
mais je pourrais dire que je
veux pas ne pas avoir d'enfant toi et ça
ça j'ai l'impression que je
sais pas j'ai l'impression qu'il y
aurait un problème si j'avais pas
d'enfant imaginaire non mon dieu je
crois pas en dieu mais je ne crois pas
au hasard non plus
est-ce que tu as une petite piste
d'action militante non violente
c'est à dire un truc qui vient comme ça
à l'esprit
[Musique]
mais c'est à dire des actions que sur
internet une petite liste d'actions
militantes non violente des idées les
idées l'action
ba on en a plein mais
trouvera trois autres
jeudi plein c'est hugo 3
le
[Musique]
c'est difficile comme ça parce que le
site ait franchi hackers citizen de
geoffrey dorne parce que ça te parle
geoffrey ne te passe le bonjour non j'ai
pas compris est-ce que tu as lu le
bouquin hackers citizen de geoffrey
dorne
revient sur thalys d'action violente non
attends je vais revenir sur la
radicalisation d'abord parce que le du
coup moi ni mon vote laisser faire ce
que ce que ce que j'observe c'est qu'il
ya des gens qui viennent avec un esprit
très constructif
très positif qui veulent développer les
alternatives qui au départ vive la
résistance comme une contradiction et
que la pratique radicalise et que en
travaillant avec les autres
s'imprègne de plus en plus de ce
sentiment d'urgence et finissent par
comprendre
l'impératif de résistance est aussi
l'utilité stratégique de la résistance
donc toi on accuse souvent les les
militants non violents d'être des
bisounours bain sans vouloir que chez
nous
sans vouloir être non mais nous on nous
accuse pas d'être des punks à chiens ce
dans l'alternative allégeance ou plutôt
mignon tout ça
le donc on est plutôt accusés d'être des
bisounours le alors s'il faut
caricaturer les choses il ya des
bisounours qui viennent dans
l'alternative à parce qu'ils disent oui
on réussira en faisant des choses bien
et en faisant que de la proposition
positive et y en a beaucoup qui se
radicalise au furet mais je lis vraiment
pour moi c'est positif c'est à dire que
il intègre en travaillant avec les
autres en échangeant en affinant leur
diagnostic de la situation que le
changement doit être plus radical que ce
qu'ils pensaient au départ parce que ça
sent le sapin et que pour obtenir ce
changement radical il faut mener des
actions de différents types qui sont
complémentaires à la fois les
alternatives mais aussi à la fois à la
fois l'opposition bon les listes
d'actions je sais pas là par exemple
le
donc il y avait ce sommet pétrolier à
pau qui se tenait quatre mois après
après la coop 21 nous on l'a vécu comme
une provocation c'est à dire que à la
cap 21 les états du monde entier se
réunissent fera dire à bon bah c'est
vrai il ya le dérèglement climatique
faut le limiter à un degré et demi et 2
degrés ce qui est jusqu'à ultra
ambitieux et ce qui du coup nous on en
déduit ma du coup faut tout changer un
degré et demi ou deux vu qu'on est déjà
un 20 degrés ça veut dire qu'on coupe le
robinet tout de suite les choses qu'ils
ne font pas et vingt quatre mois après
en france le même pays à pau il ya un
sommet qui est organisée avec toutes les
multinationales du pétrole total bp
shell exxon et leurs objectifs on avait
leur lettre d'invitation c'est moi qui
nous ont pas envoyé mais que qui est
arrivé par hasard chez nous le le hasard
fait bien les choses voilà le où c'était
le pétrole le prix du pétrole est assez
bas du coup il ya des forages en mer
profonde et très profonde potentiels qui
sont pas expliqués sont pas rentables qu
est ce qu on pourrait mutualiser comme
technique qu'est ce qu'on pourrait
trouver pour qu continuer d'exploiter
ces énergies fossiles ou cela sachant
que si on exploite déjà les énergies
fossiles qui sont accessibles on brûle
toute la planète alors du coup la
question c'est
parmi les hydrocarbures qui existent
lesquels on laisse dans le sol et c'est
eux dont il se pose la question de
comment on en a encore plus
et alors du coup on a décidé de bloquer
ce ce sommet et on s'est posé la
question le est ce que on arrive par
surprise ou est-ce qu'on l'annoncé à
l'avance
c'était en pleine semaine ça a duré
trois jours à pau vous êtes infiltrée
par les services de renseignement
peut-être vous avez protocole ii oui de
pour éviter de se faire gauler par les
écoutes téléphoniques filatures
je vais y venir du coup dans cette
histoire
on l'a annoncé on a choisi de l'annoncé
à l'avance
forcément du coup justement on peut être
écoutée on peut être infiltré mais on
les gens peuvent aussi nous rejoindre
parce que sinon tu comptes sur un petit
nombre d'activistes que tu peux
justement en contact et de manière
confidentielle sans te faire griller etc
mais du coup tu seras combien à la fin
enfin nous en tout cas on aurait été
30 ou 40 là on était 500 bondit pas trop
parce que tu es en train de dire que tu
me résoudre en tout genre et non mais
des gens qu'il faudrait que je contacte
uniquement de manière sécurisée pour
venir trois jours en semaine à pau ouais
par contre dès lors que j'en fais un
appel public et que je dis ce projet et
inaction du nous ont dit ce projet est
inacceptable
on vient de bloquer
le bas ça fait écho chez pas mal de
personnes qu'on connaît pas et qui
viennent et à la fin on est 500 à
participer à ce blocage on sait aussi du
coup qui aura la police des barrières de
sécurité et que tout sera protégé mais
comme on le sait c'est pas un problème
donc on imagine comment on fait pour
bloquer ce sommet avec avec la police en
passant ça pose quand même un dilemme à
l'organisateur du sommet qui estime ce
qu'est ce qu'on fait et ils ont dit
qu'ils venaient perturber est-ce qu on
se barricade de policiers sera terrible
pour l'image les congressistes arrivent
du monde entier tout ça enfin ça fait à
pau pour c'est une ville du pétrole les
pétroliers sont ultra respectèrent pour
plein de choses d'économie se sont fait
avec c'est le siège historique de elf
donc tout a été irriguée de pétrole donc
d'habitude tout le monde est super bien
accueilli quoi ils sont pas accueillis
avec des activistes qui disent vous êtes
en train de brûler la planète ni des
policiers pour les protéger le donc pour
nous c'est intéressant finalement les
policiers et donc on a fabriqué des
boucliers en mousse en découpant des
matelas en mousse
on sait peu de pétrole opep tête ouais
les mets de la récup en fait on avait
organisé un camp climat actions de
préparation au village d'emmaüs lescar
un grand grand village super je suis
très content de les citer parce que ils
nous ont filé vraiment énormément de
coups de main dont celui là et donc on a
tous débarqué à emmaüs et ils nous ont
filé plein de matos dont des matelas de
conte à découper on a fait des boucliers
l'intérêt de ces boucliers c'est qu' il
fallait qu'on franchisse les lignes de
police donc ils sont arrivés avec les
plastrons les trucs les matraques tout
bordel quoi et les boucliers c'était
pour pousser les policiers
et passé par la force mais et ben si
pour que ce soit violent pour que ce
soit non violent il fallait que les
boucliers soit en mousse parce que comme
ça on risque pas de les blesser et eux
mêmes voyant que c'était en mousse ne
le sait qu'il peut ne craignait pas pour
leur sécurité
pour leur intégrité physique par contre
quand on est arrivé donc en bloc à crier
des slogans sur le climat avec nos
bouclier etc c'est sûr que et qu'on a
renversé les barrières là il n'y avait
pas de policier on est rentré en courant
là où il y avait des policiers on les a
poussés c'est sûr que ça déclenche quand
même un sentiment de panique chez eux
peut-être qu'ils sont une sorte
d'agression sont ils sont simplement
utiles à prévoir pour monter pendant
deux heures dans le calme mais peut-être
aussi en tout cas il ya une intrusion
non mais là il y avait un peu un vent de
panique quoi courir partout parce qu'ils
et ils pouvaient pas sécurisé et
finalement tout le truc fait de
l'exercice il comptait sur les barrières
mais les barrières on les a fait voler
et on pourrait ont poussé des policiers
donc iriposte avec des coups de matraque
avec des gaz lacrymo et c'est
le mais comme nous on répond pas par la
violence il ya un moment où il arrête en
fait on fait trop de peine ben disons
que
c'est ça reste des professionnels il y
en a qui sont très mauvais mais ça reste
des professionnels donc ils
ont une hiérarchie donc tout doit être
piloté commandés et c'est ça aussi il
faut le savoir parce que toi si tu
trouves un système de décision plus
rapide que tu as un avantage sur le
terrain le tout est pas du genre à court
circuiter une caserne par exemple la
quinzaine de crs nouveau creux ce
n'était pas du genre à me tue de hertz
devants pour éviter qu'ils puissent
intervenir dans paris
ça m'était jamais venu à l'esprit ça
dépend ça dépend de l'action ça dépend
de
sa dépend mais
je suis je suis pas par principe contre
la dégradation matérielle ils font
rouler sur la herse c'est ça oui c'est
tout tu fais rien sur le dessus sous le
nom mais par contre la dégradation
matérielle participe très souvent d'un
imaginaire violent qui fait qu'il faut
il faut se poser la question de comment
ça va être perçue par l'opinion publique
et c'est là par exemple on en renversant
les barrières on les a abîmé on a
considéré que les gens allaient pas été
super choqué qu'on est abîmée des
barrières de ces les grandes barrières
le bon ben ça c'est un exemple d'action
non-violente particulièrement confronte
hâtives et offensive puisque là on est
carrément contact physique avec les
forces de l'ordre pour autant elle est
non violente pourquoi parce que on n'est
pas une menace pour l'intégrité physique
et parce que comme on répond pas par la
violence à la violence que il utilise
contre nous une fois qu'on est rentré on
fait des sit in devant les portes pour
empêcher les congressistes de rentrer
donc tout ça envoie dans un film qui
s'appelle irrintzi là qu'on a vu alors
qu'on a vu les techniques des crs pour
vous faire bouger en vous mettant des
pousse derrière les oreilles pour c'est
très douloureux ça s'appelle le point de
compression des points de compression on
a vu aussi
des gaz lacrymogènes projeter
directement en pleine face à moins d'un
mètre c'est une arme chimique un oui
pour s et l'utiliser en france pourquoi
vous faites pas des procès aux fins de
lutte contre les gaz lacrymogènes alors
que symbian chimiques parce que on n'a
pas le temps de tout faire mais le en
tout cas nous à ce moment là d'abord on
le savait qu'ils allaient faire ce pas
évidemment tu arrives et une épouse par
la force tu t'attends pas à ce qu'ils
disent c'est comme une sacrée démarche
psy jeudi un psychologue écologique est
de subir un point de compression
d'un mec qui est bac + 2 qui pousse de
la faune toute la journée qui attend son
camion toute la journée
quelqu'un qui a une force physique plus
important type quand même reprendre son
instinct se lever et lui péter sa rotule
quand même non eri met du coup dans
l'action non-violente la force tu fais
pour pour mode manager ça monte au t1
peut être pas très costaud non j'ai pas
très costaud
quelqu'un qui aurait envie de se faire
respecter plus tu peux comprendre sa
démarche
ouais le mais le respect ça passe par la
force mentale ça passe pas par la force
physique c'est à dire que tu te
reviendra jamais le respect de quelqu'un
en le tapant tu obtiendras son
obéissance
son voilà mais mais mais pas son respect
donc le sait la force mentale qui
qui compte la force mentale
et s'en est central dans la démarche
delà de l'action non violente mais qu'on
était comble et un flacon bêta 2
la cnacf
moment ton donc merci de forces
physiques par ta force mentale et il
faut les deux faut quand même une force
physique il fallait quand même poussé
les policiers ont renversé les barrières
courir un policier m'a fait comblé qui
loue pas non mais on était plusieurs le
nom fait la force oui mais eux aussi
sont plusieurs mais si c'est un tout
faut les prendre par surprise pour les
prendre de vitesse faut on avait une
autre technique c'était que on arrive et
on se renversait des bouteilles de
peinture sur la tête les premières
lignes juste au moment où on arrive au
contact des forces de l'ordre ce qu'on
voulait c'était que parce que s'ils sont
responsables de leur matériel donc ils
veulent pas le salir si non en fait
c'est il faut qu'ils nettoient et puis
voilà et du coup le le ce qu'on voulait
c'était que il est un geste de surprises
et un réflexe de protection de leurs
équipements qui recule et on avait
imaginé ensuite qu'on passait entre
leurs jambes et ou alors ça s'est passé
de manière un peu plus bordélique que ça
mais ça a fini qu'ils avaient de la
peinture partout le troisième jour de
blocage le premier truc qui faisait
quand ils nous arrêtent et c'est
balancer toutes les bouteilles de
peinture un peu plus loin dans l'ail sur
le truc qui voulait absolument passer se
retrouve avec deux avec l'attention de
ménage avec de la peinture veille du
troisième jour il revenait il avait déjà
de la peinture dessus et il n'avait pas
eu le temps de deux filles pouvaient pas
nettoyer leur truc quoi mais moralité si
vous voulez chercheur au cnrs la
maskinongé vous ait eu un ouais ouais
mais alors tu vois là aussi où c'était
non violence et qu'on leur a pas lancé
leurs peintures dessus on laisse la
renverser sur nous et c'est eux qui s'en
sont mis dessus en nous arrêtant et en
nous empêchant en tout cas c'était
encore plus longuement que de leur jeter
de la peinture on pourrait considérer
que jeter de la peinture c'est déjà non
violent mais c'était plus agressifs pour
eux que si c'est eux mêmes qui se met
dedans évidemment mais ce que je tiens à
dire quand même pour compléter c'est que
on a eu une aussi beaucoup d'échangés
avec les policiers c'est à dire que une
fois alors la violence
soit ça provoque une une contre violence
et sa enclenche l'escaladé de la
violence qui a plutôt tendance à faire
que chacun devient un peu plus violents
à chaque fois le manque de dialogue ah
ben ça laisse pas la place ça laisse pas
la place au dialogue mais surtout celle
escalade de la violence ou le cercle
vicieux de la violence qui fait que
comment tu t'arrêtes parce que plus tu
as subi de la violence et 6 qui t'anime
c'est le sentiment de la vengeance et la
souffrance que bad comme tu en a de plus
en plus tu as encore enfin voilà donc
c'est vraiment une logique de cercle
vicieux
le le situe si tu réagi autrement que
par la violence alors faut trouver quoi
mais effectivement c'est essayé de leur
parler c'est dit c'est dire vous me
faites mal on est non violent
bon bref défaut trouver quoi
le il ya un moment où effectivement tu
désamorce le leur violence
alors et puis c'est un tout ça tient à
plusieurs choses il y en a qui
leur consigne c'est d'appliquer une
force en fait c'est une violence mais
une force proportionnée à la menace
donc c'est leur boulot de réduire la
violence une fois qu'on se retrouve
assis devant la porte ils font pas tous
comme tu dis il y en a un qui faisait on
était assis il y en a un qui faisait le
point de compression c'est extrêmement
douloureux il faisait souffrir quelqu'un
pour rien alors que là là un vrai tortul
ans c'est la tortue louis et bah oui oui
et du coup
alors que là il y a les gens sont pas en
danger c'est juste les congressistes qui
sont en retard parce que pendant ce
temps les effectivement les
congressistes sont bloqués les
pétroliers donc donc pour moi c'est pas
un usage proportionné de la force mais y
en a plein d'autres qui l'ont pas fait
la place beauvau qui ont dit allez il
faut vous lever et c'est avec qui nous
ont portés en poids mort ce qu'on
appelle se dire banon fait rien on a
écouté le championnat il y en a certains
qui sont très poli très courtois qui est
celui de et lounge et là où je veux en
venir c'est que moi je pense qu'on peut
parler aux policiers ne vont pas te
répondre parce qu'ils ont un devoir de
réserve et je pense que c'est une bonne
chose qui conte elle pas leurs opinions
politiques à comment il gère le
rétablissement de l'ordre le temps d un
vrai dialogue pour qu'il pose le 15 41
bah évidemment c'est
celle des hommes
j'avais vu une image de manifestations
en italie où il posait de 15 les
policiers en signe de solidarité que les
manifestants avaient enlevé leur casque
c'est super émouvant parce qu'il y en a
un qui enlève son casque les autres se
regarde et il enlève tous leurs casques
là aussi il ya des choses à comprendre
de
du collectif de cette sorte de contagion
qui peut être positive entre les forces
de l'ordre mais qui est passé des
manifestants aux forces de l'ordre mois
en fait ce que je pense c'est que les
enfants des policiers sont aussi menacés
que les nôtres le ils ont autant
d'intérêt que nous à ce que on ne
détruisent pas les conditions de vie
civilisée sur sur la terre et qu'ils
sont capables de comprendre ça je pense
que dans beaucoup de moments de
l'histoire les les mouvements non
violents il ya eu un point de bascule
quand les forces de l'ordre les
policiers les militaires ont refusé
d'exécuter les ordres ils ont dit non on
va pas tirer sur la foule le est alors
quand je parle aux policiers c'est ça
que je vise mais j'ai pas la naïveté de
croire qu'il va le faire tout de suite
parce que je comprends bien que au
moment où je lui dis il est dans une
situation de contradiction très forte il
ay la hiérarchie son boulot il
s'attendait pas à ce que à être dans
cette situation là donc il ne peut pas
avoir la prise de conscience c'est quand
même un processus plus complexe que dire
mais c'est vrai vous avez raison en fait
les pc les pétroliers qu'il faudrait
virer et puis bien sûr qu'on pourra pas
ça
le met ce que je me dis c'est que dans
cinq ans dans dix ans
oui je pense que c'est possible qu'un
jour les policiers si on continue de
leur donner l'ordre de protéger les
pétroliers alors que beaucoup beaucoup
plus de gens auront compris que c'est
des gens qui sont en train de nous tuer
si des gens qui sont en train de donner
d un gel des colonies aussi est-ce que
tu connais que tu connaissais christophe
de margerie bah je le connaissais pas
personnellement le messie ni justes sur
ça
il arrivera peut-être ce jour où les
policiers diront non
notre rôle de protéger la population ça
passe ça passe par empêcher ces pétroles
et de faire ça jamais c'est l'armée qui
fait ça ça la police est toujours du
côté de l'état l'armée l'arrêt est
toujours du côté de la population
bon mais alors les gendarmes et alors du
coup aujourd'hui où les gendarmes
une affection particulière pour le les
gendarmes alors admettons que seuls les
armes pourraient le faire mais ça serait
déjà pas mal de plus le les les
gendarmes
le jour où ils font ça justement parce
que c'est pas quelque chose qui se
décident en une seconde s'ils font ça un
jour ce sera aussi pour toutes les fois
où des gens leur ont parlé en essayant
de les persuader c'est à dire que moi
quand je parle aux policiers il va
peut-être pas être qu'on a il va il va
pas changer de camp tout de suite mais
le jour où il sort d'une opération
psychologique des jours où il change de
camp ce sera grâce à tous les gens qui
ont aidé à lui faire prendre à lui faire
prendre conscience et jusqu'au point où
il prend une décision radicale au point
de vous et des arts de oui-oui ou en
tout cas de changer de camp on arrive
bientôt la fin de notre interview
le livre à coeur citizen de geoffrey
dorne ça tu parles je conseille est-ce
que tu as un avis sur nicolas hulot
parce que c'est un branquignol est ce
qu'ils essaient de faire tout ce qu'il
peut avec la faible marge de manoeuvre
qu'il a est ce que c'est un millionnaire
qui a rentré au gouvernement sans trop
savoir où ils iront trail qu'est ce
qu'est ce que tu en penses alors déjà
nicolas hulot
maintenant il est ministre on mais
c'était déjà un parcours intéressant
avant qu'il soit ministre il incarnait
déjà
ce point d'interrogation entre
ou et le pragmatisme et la compromission
et c'est
le moi je pense que c'est quelqu'un de
deux sincèrement convaincu
par ce qui se passe
vu que notre bureau qui s'est convertie
c'est à dire que en fait pour résumer et
finalement nicolas hulot c'est
presque une caricature de quelqu'un qui
considérait que la planète était un
grand terrain de jeu
puisque il faisait ses émissions d'
aventure à faire du jet ski du machin du
truc à moteur de petite ou voilà donc
c'était plutôt le
le sport extrême ou le truc aventure et
la nature là dedans été le décor quoi et
c'est sauf que comme il a fait ça de
nombreuses années il en est arrivé à des
situations où il retournait sur des
lieux qu'ils avaient connue magnifique
et qui avait été complètement détruit et
il a pris du coup il a pris conscience
des enjeux écologiques comme ça ça peut
être vachement puissant la conscience
écologique que tu que tu que tu as un
chance ben voilà le
le donc je moi je pense vraiment qu'il
est sincèrement animé que c'est
quelqu'un que le dérèglement climatique
ça empêche de dormir la nuit c'est pas
en train de dire ça pour qu'il vienne
tôt thomas minc un petit discours un
petit dialogue avec lui ni d'eau n'ont
cessé verdict oui oui je pense que quand
le
le bas tu vois quand même avant qu'il
soit ministre moi je trouve que c'est
une des rares personnes qui continuait
en interview de rappeler l'urgence
climatique même quand tout le monde
avait arrêté de le faire et qui a
toujours été dans l'effort d'expliquer
ce qui se passait et il ya une forme
d'exigences alors après ce qui est
compliqué avec son cas
c'est que en fait il a une position
complètement complètement inédite c'est
à dire que il avait l'oreille des
présidents de chirac de hollande de
sarkozy alors du coup maintenant ils les
gouvernements de macron mais c'est le
seul il ya ya ya aucun autre militant
écolo qui peut qui avait comme ça qu'ils
pouvaient avoir une réunion en tête à
tête avec un président de la république
pour lui expliquer bon l'écologie en
fait tu vois le discours la maison brûle
on regarde ailleurs de chirac c'était
lui les
et moi je me dis je serais à sa place je
te coupe chou couple je m'autorise non
tu es président de la république tu vois
bien que ça part en couilles
j'ai parlé au président pays qui n'a pas
besoin du parle ici tu as un tant soit
peu bien formés dans ta tête et ouvre
les yeux vrai et et qui était pas besoin
d'un nicolas loupe pour voir que quand
tu prends l'autoroute après avoir acheté
moins d'impact non mais des degré de
croyance
il faut arrêter l'écologie lui à la
fonction exponentielle de consommation
et namibiennes contradictions donc après
mai mais macron je suis désolé pour ceux
ne pas entonner ya une forme de
schizophrénie en fait je pense que macro
ils l'ignorent pas
la situation écologique mais à mon avis
ça m'attriste c'est tellement la finance
l'économie et c'est qu'il arrive à
croire deux choses en même temps qu'ils
sont qui sont contradictoires ou le fait
qu'ils ne veulent pas laisser son nid
comme le président qui a laisser
s'effondrer la france
ouais peut-être doux qui propose de
continuer à minima mais quand même de
continuer le système pour éviter que ça
ce gouffre en tout cas juste pour finir
ce faire dit vous sur nico le louvre est
parce que le le brave type non mais je
mets je sais alors avant qu'il soit
ministre en tout cas je me disais c'est
sûr que quand tu es le seul dans cette
position là tu essaies de faire quelque
chose qui je pense qu'il essaie toujours
de faire ce qui est le plus utile et
c'est vrai que lui il cherche jamais le
point de rupture parce qu'il a
l'impression de perdre 7 7 cette
position qu'il est le seul où avoir
j'interprète les choses comme ça
maintenant qu'il est ministre me pose
une autre question c'est quand on voit
bien qu'on n'ait pas
être un plus si les ministres d'état
c'est pas rien c'est à dire qu' il n'est
pas tout en bas de la hiérarchie donc on
serait en droit d'attendre que ça avance
plus il applique ses propres principes
s'étonner bien sûr d'en avoir 25 bagnols
par un char ça c'est autre chose c'est
plutôt les contradictions personnel mais
là sur l'action politique
qui les mangent de la viande non une
voiture oui tout déplace en vélo aussi
tu as évolué et a évolué et on coût
carbone allégée des contradictions de
quelques contradictions et quant à la
manière comme ça on dirait jésus l'un
mais j'habite à la campagne donc
j'utilise la voiture et parce que je si
tu veux à part
pour transformer le système mais il faut
garder un pied dans le système par
exemple tu vois j'ai un smartphone mais
vraiment juste parce que je suis
militant je n'ai aucune autre applique
voile
l'utilisation de mon smartphone que de
que que de militer et je serais super
heureux le jour où je pourrai atteindre
en face de mon smartphone et est
d'ailleurs la dernière fois c'était
tombé dans une rivière je l'avais cas
cgt mais j'ai c'était super enfin
pendant j'avais glissé pendant une
semaine j'avais plus de smartphones
vraiment donc oui j'assume mes
contradictions mais franchement c'est
pas c'est pas ce type de contradictions
qu'on croit je suis pas content de moi
d'avoir un smartphone la bagnole je
n'aime pas spécialement faire de la
bagnole ou alors on me dit que je suis
ni guiglo sa draft voilà c'est pas ça en
tout cas je me pose vraiment là moi je
me pose la question du jugement a voulu
parler maintenant qu'il est mais le
maintenant qu'il est ministre je me pose
la question est-ce qu effectivement
ils n'utilisent pas assez le rapport de
force il va pas assez à la rupture peu
pincé sévèrement burné ce que ce que ce
que beaucoup de gens disent est ce que
c'est ça ou est-ce que c'est autre chose
c'est à dire que est ce qu'il fait
vraiment le maximum en toute lucidité
faut pas toujours aller à la rupture
pour aller à la rupture des fois ça ne
fait pas gagner plus donc c'est toujours
un calcul tu peux te tromper dans le
calcul mais est ce qu'il est vraiment en
train d'essayer de pousser au maximum à
chaque fois le truc ou pas ou est ce que
c'est parce que dans un gouvernement si
tu es le seul à avoir ses convictions là
que tu as bruno le maire non et bruno le
maire edouard philippe qui est un ancien
du nucléaire macron qui était de la
finance un ancien de rothschild et c'est
en fait la question que je me pose c'est
que seul contre tous semblent comparer à
nicolas hulot et c est tout son parcours
je suis plus jeune et ça mais je veux
dire est ce que quelqu'un de comté ou
quelqu'un qu'on tiendrait pour le
militant super radical je me demandais
ce qu'il ferait mieux et est ce qu'il
arriverait à mieux que nicolas hulot je
me pose vraiment la question bien vision
et g non mais non ça ça se trouve
j'aurai un regard dur sur son truc mais
mais en fait j'en sais rien je ne sais
pas ce qui se passe dans un gouvernement
je sais pas si il fait tout nu je ne
sais pas et
j'aimerais avoir la réponse est je pense
que là c'est un peu tôt pour avoir la
réponse
mais vraiment ça m'intéresse ça
m'intéresse parce que ça nous permettra
ensuite
pour le gouvernement suivant où le
ministre suivant et c'est de vraiment
savoir ce qu'on peut attendre d'un
ministre parce que parce qu'on pourrait
poser la question autrement est ce que
nicolas hulot on en est content ou pas
mais qui on voudrait à la place de
nicolas hulot à ses ministères pour toi
un bon ministre de l'écologie c'est est
ce que c'est un ministre de l'écologie
qu'est capable de simuler sur le lol
je vais pas dire les trous de l'elysée
mais sur le perron de l'elysée pour
faire prendre conscience que la france
va mal
et ce canal est ce que non parce qu'un
ministre de l'écologie doit se sacrifier
pour sa cause quand il est dans le
gouvernement c'est un chose imola non
mais voilà compris c'est une figure
qui était un militant pour les droits
lgbt à new york un avocat et qui a qui
était devenue là dans ces derniers temps
un militant environnementaliste qui
s'est immolé pour alerter et gc c'est
une figure ans d'une fille rate est-ce
qu'il doit se sacrifier mais donc
ministre pour faire prendre conscience à
sa population un autre population que ça
va vraiment mal en b en fait que tu
trouves que le nicolas luz sacrifie mais
moi la question que je me pose à travers
celle là c'est est ce que c'est la bonne
action à faire si c'est la bonne action
à faire oui doit la faire et est ce que
ça fait partie des actions possibles
qu'il faut se poser oui il faut se poser
l'éventualité de cette action le et moi
je pense qu'ils se la posent j'imagine
qu'ils se la posent le kun open ouais on
peut non mais tu vois bien aussi
tu vois pas qu'il est dans la tentative
c'est à dire qu'il a vachement hésité
avant de se présenter chez les verts ça
sentait quand même vachement le piège tu
vois enfin je veux dire on sentait qu'il
était pas une caution on sentait qu'il
était attendu au tournant par par denis
que je sais c'est un peu petit clown
non mais moi je
on pense beaucoup de vent ce gars là non
bah non je fumais peut-être
non je pense que c'est difficile de
porter un discours écolo quand tu es
dans un rôle de
darksiders ii je trouve que j'ai 12 ans
au leader outsiders c'est à dire que tu
vois pas lucho pour le personnage c'est
à dire que c'est justement pas la
personne à qui trois présidents
d'affilée ont proposé le ministère de
l'écologie donc forcément tu mènes pas
le combat de la même manière que quand
c'est les présidents qui le demande
tient bien dans mon gouvernement grec de
taquiner parce qu'on a eu à la fin on
aurait bien continué question d'internet
qui est d'ailleurs très très bonne
comment lutter contre les policiers
infiltrés qui cassent exprès pour tenir
l'image des manifestants et qui quatre
ans et moi les remuer année j'ai compris
les manifestants et contrôler l'opinion
publique en gros les agents
perturbateurs qui se met dans la main
dans la foulée manifestons pour faire
basculer l'image de l'opinion publique
contre les manifestants bon le préalable
pour ça c'est qu' un cadre d'action qui
soit posée clairement par les
organisateurs de l'action ou de la
manifestation parce que si c'est pas le
cas bon ben on peut rien faire chacun
fait ce qu'il veut donc
le
et en manif c'est un peu ça bat en manif
même quand le cadre est clairement posée
on voit qu'il ya eu
il ya eu de la casse alors qu'elle est
d'ailleurs ce qu'on peut souligner c'est
qu'on ne sait pas si c'est des agents
infiltrés ou des anti capitaliste où des
militants d'extrême droite on n'en sait
rien de plus qu ils sont cagoulés
le moi j'avais vu quelque chose chez les
ch et les indignés espagnols dans une
vidéo où il y avait justement alors les
indignés espagnols mouvement populaire
radical non violent visage découvert
occupation des places des clés dès que
les policiers arrivent il lève les mains
en signe de non violence etc
et du coup ils s'étaient infiltrées par
par des policiers qu'il n'est cassé un
peu kaboul et ils se dissocier il
s'écarte et il s'écarte et y en a même
qui monte qui montrait du doigt et du
coup et on a vu une séquence assez
incroyable où tu as d'autres gens qui
viennent un espèce d'exfiltration et qui
le ramène et on le voit plus loin d'un
camion de police situation au gentil
s'il ne lui était pas les jeunes ou non
ses copains sert qu'une fois que le flic
été grillés ils sont allés le chercher
dans la manif pour pour parce qu'ils
étaient grillés quoi
le en tout cas on a plusieurs d'entre
eux tulle comme ça d'agents
perturbateurs en coulisses est pas mal
non non mais là il aurait donc qu'il
reçoit les manifestants qu'ils fassent
tu veux dire non là les manifestants ils
se disent aussi non bon alors si y'a pas
de cadres ben on assume qui n'est pas de
gardanne dans ce cas chacun fait ce
qu'il veut j'ouvre une parenthèse quand
on a notre ministre ministre de
l'intérieur qui dit les manifestants
doivent neutraliser les casseurs
comment il est gentil mais on verra on
se passera de ses conseils parce que là
c'est une référence sur à peu près rien
pour l'instant je trouve qu'on a on
aurait beaucoup de choses à lui
reprocher mais donc non c'est
mais
en plus si les mystères de limites de
l'intérieur donc c'est son boulot quoi
donc cessé même pas logique qu'il
demande qui demande qu'on fasse ça le
parce que c'est légitime de le demander
c'est pas mes clients des applications
avec un marc tout un petit doute si
c'est un flic infiltré ou pour infiltrer
un petit coup dans la rotule dans cette
mais non mais parce que c'est efficace 1
2 seconde c'est notre alizés l'outil
where does surtout moi je m'en prends
aussi déjà au courant oui c'est vrai
plus gros lycée non non non juste un
tout petit bikini latéral sur l'un ou
cultes comme s'abîme mais non le rimbaud
dont violent
oui mais parce que sinon je dis ça pour
te provoque mais qu'est ce qui va se
passer si je mets une béquille à un mec
cagoulés il va dire ah tu le saches
directement payés et puis on rentre chez
lui à dire mais la véraison
effectivement j'étais venu perturber un
truc les gens a été dans une posture
plus de 1800 euros pour ce faire péter
le jeu donc on est d'accord que c'est
pas ça qui va se passer tu te fait
violenter
tu as envie d'être violent donc du coup
il va pas avoir envie des violents un
petit coup dans la rotule latéral il est
neutralisé direct pacific à saint leu
bord de toute façon ça sert à rien dans
notre accueil et provenir à gérard
collomb
est ce que les manifestants doivent
neutraliser les casseurs
alors non en tout cas surtout pas quand
c'est lui qui le demande le
mais encore une fois ça dépend du cadre
qu'est posée dans les manifestations je
vais finir cette phase là si y'a pas de
cadres
bas chacun fait ce qu'il veut si un
cadre qui a été appelé en disant cette
action c'est la diversité des tactiques
on mélange des non violent des violents
combats les gens ils vont en
connaissance de cause ceux qui ont envie
d'être non violents ils sont environ
mais ils savent qui aura quand même de
la violence autour ce qui va de violents
ils sont violents et puis ceux qui
disent la violence et jusqu'à ses mets
pas les gens pas s'attaquer aux gens
d'autres qui diront c'est aussi
s'attaquer aux gens ça peut aller
jusqu'à action directe qui dira ce sera
assassiné des grands patrons etc enfin
je veux dire tous les critères sont
possibles le si un cadre ensuite la
question c'est comment on fait respecter
mais en tout cas je me pose pas la
question de comment on neutralise les
casseurs hors de tout cadre si c'est le
cas d'un ben moi je vais pas aller
m'amuser à les neutraliser l'action des
gens qui ont posé ça comme cadre par
contre si je participe à un groupe qui
organise une manifestation de masse non
violente que c'est annoncé comme non
violent que c'est notre stratégie que
notre analyse des rapports de force et
ses envies un objectif stratégique à
travers ça que tous les participants
sont venus pour servir cet objectif et
pour être non violent alors s'il ya une
action violente
kaboul est alors que ça a été a appelé à
visage découvert de casse alors qu'on
avait dit qu'on cassait pas et cetera
alors clairement ça me met en péril
notre stratégie salle à sa botte pour
dire clairement les choses parce que
évidemment les images seront pas les
mêmes il se passe des choses qu'on n'a
pas anticipé la répression sera pas la
même se racontent une autre histoire
l'adversaire a beaucoup des arguments
différents
aa nous opposer
le et donc c'est très différent toi
c'est comme si quand ont réquisitionné
des chaises quelqu'un disait mais moi je
vais aller péter la vitrine aussi
évidemment la bnp il irait mais regardez
ils nous volent les chaînes ou pet la
vitrine j'aurais peut-être pas été
relaxé parce que on n'avait pas du tout
la même ligne de défense pour autant
dans l'absolu je dis pas qu'il faut pas
péter de vitrines moi je ça ça dépend le
donc petit rotules donc non non parce
que ça c'est on est sûr que la personne
va souffrir elle la vitrine c'est pour
ça que je me dis il ya débat quoi ça
dépend ça dépend de la vitrine le le
mais en tout cas il faut que soit décidé
à l'avancé et assumé publiquement ce coq
pour nous doit dans la nv comme 21 dans
l'action non violente comme 21 la
dégradation matérielle c'est que décider
collectivement et assumé publiquement et
voilà donc dans ce cas là la réaction
c'est la dissociation c'est à dire que
l'action de toute façon et foire est
donc la seule chose qu'on peut encore
sauver c'est ne pas être amalgamés et
que l'adversaire
se servent de ça pour nous taper dessus
surtout que tu as eu raison de dire au
début que ça se trouve c'est pas du tout
quelqu'un anticapitaliste qui visent le
même objectif que nous avec des moyens
différents clans c'est que c'est
peut-être effectivement un
agent perturbateurs comme tu disais qui
peut être aussi un policier infiltré des
rats
voilà donc le donc oui il faut
neutraliser cette tactique et comment
cette vie sociale campeuse rotules
non mais bon quand on s'écarte on
s'écarte on s'assoit et oui mais non
parce que ça neutralisent l'action parce
que si tu t'assois
se retrouve tout seul ben voilà où ici
sont dits se retrouve à dix mais en tout
cas il le mettre à genoux les ont vus ce
qui roule prendre des photos ou non
parce qu'en fait ça c'est plus effilé le
met à poil et renault ne nous devrons
non plus non mais on va pas non plus à
les regarder qui s'est dénoncé appelé
les flics regarder telle personne qui a
lancé un flic au bureau en est sûrs pas
ce n'est pas une science exacte à un peu
fou info donc du coup le nom la
dissociation c'est le mieux parce que
c'est ce qui permet à ces personnes de
partir donc nous de qu'on soit ou que
notre mouvement soit pas abîmer ou le
moins possible eux
ils restent le leur initiative et ils
peuvent partir on les livre pas à la
police nous on s'assoit et eux peuvent
s'en aller ou rester c'est eux qui
décident mais
dont 4 ap le ligoter non mais non mais
tu vois bien c'est que le
le problème que pose cette action dans
une action violente c'est la violence
donc si on y répond par la violence en
revanche
on aggrave le problème mais en plus moi
je pense qu'il ya des gens comme je
disais je respecte la colère des gens
mais il faut que l'on apprenne dans dans
nos mouvements à respecter les
stratégies et les cadres de chacun c'est
à dire que moi je crois la stratégie non
violente et j'entends qu'on respecte mon
choix stratégiques et que quand je mets
des efforts et que je développe quelque
chose j'entends qu'on le respecte et
quand d'autres personnes développent des
stratégies de la diversité où je pense
que ça produit absolument pas les mêmes
résultats de mélanger la non violence
est la violence mais
je ne nie pas qu'il ya un vrai
raisonnement une vraie réflexion est un
vrai calcul à travers ça moi j'y trouve
pas mon compte et j'ai beaucoup de
doutes sur l'efficacité mais je peux me
tromper eux ils y croient et eux ils ont
ils ont mis leur temps ils ont mis leurs
efforts pour le faire donc je vais pas
aller saboter leur travail donc moi je
le respecte de cette de cette manière là
mais de la même manière encore que
quelqu'un qui choisiraient la lutte
armée j'ai pas un c'est le on va pas
juger les résistants qui ont choisi la
lutte armée contre contre les nazis et
cetera donc ça dépend des contextes mais
le est-ce qu est ce qui compte c'est que
chacun qui s'engagent dans un mouvement
s'engage en connaissance de cause c'est
à dire que le cadre d'actions soit clair
qu'est ce que t'es pris un risque et
j'ai une question que je me pose au fur
et à mesure le
plus vite parce que je voulais pas
beaucoup de temps
bah là en l'occurrence
c'est
moi je suis passé
j'ai eu trois procès donc j'ai risqué
trois fois
la prison l'an 4,4 procès
je suis je suis fichu j'en sais rien
mais j'imagine que oui le affichait ce
faux nom je pense que ce serait pas du
tout
bas normalement quand même car c'est
vrai qu'on peut douter de consensus la
fim vrai je viens le nom mais disons que
normalement je suis pas une menace pour
la sécurité surtout si c'est pour la
sécurité fétis bonus pour les intérêts
de l'état oui c'est pas c'est encore
pire c'est peut-être encore pire mais
c'est pas la même chose
et quand même un peu bisounours
leu leu donc bon bah dans la
désobéissance civile tut tut tut risque
la prison pour l'instant je pense pas
que j'aie jamais respire le sculpteur
vie j'ai jamais vraiment risquer la
prison ferme jusque là quand même de ce
qu'il te fiche c'était la prison avec
sursis et j'en ai mais
ça m'embêterait un peu quand même ouais
et mais c'est toujours pareil pour quoi
faire
mais la question est très théorique si
ma vie permettait à l'ensemble de la
planète de s'en sortir tout voir je sais
pas par quelle situation absolument
improbable juste moi juste magique tout
le poids de la police ou non
le jeu je me poserai la question est
bien évidemment que j'hésiterais parce
que je tiens ma vie et en même temps
mort à tous un jour quoi donc si ta vie
permet à la planète d'être sauvé c'est
un bon calcul mais par contre mourir
pour rien non
dernière question qui n'est pas une
question qui est laissé un conseil pour
les jeunes générations une bouteille à
la mer
chez toi bats les jeunes générations
moi je dirais que
il ya beaucoup de combat qui mérite
d'être mené
et
chacun va être animée par
va commencer un engagement d'une manière
ou d'une autre ça dépend de ce qui t'a
indigné en premier qui ensuite te fais
prendre un certain parcours donc ça peut
être un truc de par rapport aux migrants
ça peut être que qu'on accueille pas
c'est bien ça peut être un truc par
rapport à l'injustice sociale ça peut
être sur l'écologie ça peut être sur
plein de choses
mais je pense qu'il faut vraiment relier
toutes les luttes
à celle du climat et je dis pas parce
que moi la météo ça m'a jamais passionné
c'est pas je suis pas un passionné de
météo ni le climat je suis pas un
passionné de climatologie mais vraiment
je pense que le
le la situation écologique et ce qui
détermine tout le reste donc des fois je
trouve
qu'il ya quelque chose d'assez dérisoire
à mener des batailles avec énormément de
détermination si on fait pas le lien
avec l'horizon commun qu'elles notre de
est ce qu'on va pouvoir juste continuer
à vivre sur cette planète on est en
train de résister pour garder des droits
ou ou de se battre pour avoir des droits
qui est de toute façon seront balayés
par des forces qu'on maîtrise pas qui
sont celles de la nature qu'on des
règles ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
mettre tous les combats de côté et
bataille que pour le climat ça veut dire
autre chose ça veut dire que la manière
dont on s'engage dans tous ses combats
pour la solidarité avec les migrants
pour la justice sociale pour des emplois
juste avec une réduction de temps de
travail etc
doivent être menées avec un horizon
commun qui est la préservation de la
situation écologique de la planète parce
que c'est la première condition qui nous
permet de vivre john paul merci merci à
toi
[Musique]
e